hey I'm Ben Shapiro and welcome to a
very special edition of the Reuben
report one Jew replacing another joining
me today on his new set after thirty
four glorious days off the grid is the
host of the Reuben report Dave Rubin
welcome back and I'm sorry dude
Shapiro I feel like I'm in the twilight
zone right now
truly I really do I mean first time
you're hosting my show we're on a new
set here new chairs new carpet new table
new art do everything I have no idea
genuinely genuinely I have no idea
what's going on in the world since yeah
August first I know one thing that I
found out two days ago because my dad
could not control himself in an idiotic
phone call so I know one thing I suspect
it's a pretty big thing that that has
happened I know you have a list I have a
list of 20 things here 20 things you
missed during the last month because as
we all know one month of time in Trump
world is actually seven years of regular
time so but let's talk first about like
what it was like to actually be off the
grid for for 34 days so I do it like
once a week but you did it for 34
straight days which has got to be both
wonderful and also now you have to feel
like you just jump directly into a
cesspool of crap
well I haven't jumped in yet I think I
will assure you there is no cesspool of
crap right there
I mean first time I just I feel great I
genuinely mean that like as I think
because a minute with a little bit of
runway here and then you're gonna you
know take us off into the ditch but like
just in terms of like how I feel as a
human being right now my mind feels
clear I feel good I feel positive I feel
very grateful for the things that I have
oh this last month I mean really I don't
know that I heard the word Trump more
than three times truly like you know how
every conversation now that anyone has
anywhere and I'm not even just talking
about the world we live in but just
everywhere people talk about Trump all
the time talking about politics all the
time everyone thinks World War 3
starting tomorrow where the Russians are
just like this endless like rancor
monster of insanity
and I didn't have any of it for a month
I'm telling you that every interaction
that I had with the human being since
August 1st and
today's September 4th was good it was
decent weather I was talking to cashiers
or waitresses or the girl at the
hardware store who I've told you about
who every time at this local hardware
store I go to she always goes Oh Dave I
love you but I really love that ben
shapiro it turns out that the hardware
store is closing and i said to her the
other day i said well good luck and
whatever you're gonna do when she was
like don't worry about it i'm going to
grad school now and it was just like
talking to different people and i try to
do all that anyway and not be online all
the time and not focus on the hate and
all that monstrosity but i just i feel
freaking clear man I really do and I'm
psyched that we that we did all these
changes around here and beautiful yeah
thank you for coming in and doing this
you know the guy who read The Game of
Thrones books and then was waiting for
the rest of the world to catch up on the
red wedding this is gonna be the Reg
it's pretty wild but first I want to ask
you about like how hard was it to
actually you know shut yourself off to
actually put that phone in that safe
because yeah man I do it once a week but
you know the rest of the week I find
myself with the phones in my pocket I'm
checking Twitter almost as a reflex at
this point how hard was it to actually
put it down for a month
well first off I I want to give a little
credit to the Orthodox Jews out there
because perhaps this Shabbat thing has
well I guess it's not just the Orthodox
thing but has figured something out with
getting off technology well done God
because yeah so here's one for God right
because look I do I try to do the
weekends off in general but I struggle
with it sometimes and a lot of times if
I'm on the road you know I've been on
the road with Peterson for the last
couple months so like if I'm on the road
it's like yeah what else am I going to
be doing you know I can visit some
tourist stuff and have some dinners or
whatever but I'm feeling around it you
know I did this thing last month last
year last August and it was it was
basically you know the first couple days
you've owned it's your pocket all the
time like literally you feel your phone
there or you get those phantom
vibrations all of that stuff and you
feel like you need it or you know what I
noticed was weird like if you're just if
I was just waiting for somebody like
when's the last time you just like
waited on a corner yeah for somebody you
automatically look at your phone yeah
you don't just stand there even for 10
seconds you don't just stand there and
kind of like
around or people watch or just think or
look at the sky or anything you
literally just go to your phone that
moment so that sort of thing I noticed
that in the moments of quiet where I was
doing nothing if I was in-between things
but even if I was taking a [ __ ] I'm on
my phone usually I am and I suspect what
everyone's doing it but guess what I was
pooping phone free and then you have
moments to think I mean I know this all
sounds having by pooping phone free in
them but I'm sorry that we did this but
well it just look even this like
avoiding the news in general is also
work because what I realized is when
you're off this for a little while we
are slammed with this nonsense all the
time and when I say nonsense I don't
mean the important things that I think
you and I and a bunch of other people
are trying to talk about and trying to
deal with the difficult questions of the
day and I'm sure we're gonna get into
some of that but just the endless 24
hour news cycle of just drivel that
keeps everybody angry at each other and
and confused about truth and distracted
and clicking and all that even avoiding
CNN when you're not looking at
television and don't have a phone was
hard CNN is wherever a muted television
is period it's everywhere airports
it's at the gym it's at the local you're
gonna go to a burger joint it's playing
or a diner or whatever everywhere I went
to get my car tuned up its playing in
the lobby there and I had to literally
avoid watch you know because there
everything's breaking news and none of
its really breaking they're actually
breaking news but you know you I had to
actually avoid that so I was at the gym
and they have all these TVs up there and
I had to literally do cardio with my
head down because I didn't even want oh
boy that so we're just like slammed with
all of this stuff and I think when you
step away from it a little bit that I
know you're very excited to get me back
in but when you step away from a little
bit it does give you a little
perspective and I was also thinking
about things like I mean as I said every
interaction I had was positive like this
idea that we live in this country of
like endlessly racist evil people when
you're out there actually talking to
real people you know and again I do this
I tried to do as much of this as I can
normally but when were also in this
digital thing
it's like it's not like that people are
good people want the same thing yeah
like I so fundamentally believe that and
I I've always believed it but I really
really believe it now I used to think
that the hope for the country rested and
you know the 40% of the population that
was following this stuff closely and the
more I viewed the stuff now I'm starting
to think that the future of the country
rests with the 60% who really do not
follow this stuff closely well that's
the thing it's like well what do you do
then because part of me literally like a
week ago and I knew I was about to come
back I was like man like I ever come
back fine else to do I wanted to be in
the NBA like why I'm saying else you
know and not that you I mean you know
how much like you really know how much I
love this and like I think what we're
doing is so important and I think I'm a
better person now and all this stuff and
and after being on tour with Peterson
for months where for months I've been
performing in front of thousands of
people every night and it's this great
love fest of people who are getting
their lives together and disagree on
what the marginal political issues are
but like all of that greatness and it's
like I could see because of because of
all the evil that is out there and when
I say evil I mean just like the hate and
all the people that want to keep you
clicking and angry and distracted and
and fighting with everybody I could see
why a lot of good people that we really
need would just be like I'm out
altogether
I'm never gonna post again and I'm never
gonna read this you know and and that's
a real problem because then if we push
out all the good people now you have the
middle majority that's endlessly just
being slammed by one side dare I say
that's partly why I think this whole
intellectual dark web thing has has
taken root and has some meaning now it's
because I think for all of our
differences which we've discussed many
of them including abortion and death
penalty and a whole bunch of other
things it's like we're trying to
basically live in the same society
together and and not hate each other for
whatever those differences are and as I
said to you last time you were you were
sitting here it's like on something like
abortion where we disagree it's like you
know what hopefully for the next 50
years we'll do this and then maybe when
I'm a little older than you so I'm 92
and where are you gonna be in 50 years
I'll be 84 and you're 84 like maybe one
of us will have moved one of us one way
or another
you're looking at me going Ruben you're
not gonna move me but you know who knows
what happens over the course of time but
the only thing that will allow that and
we're looking you like I don't know if
me alive that's why I would recommend a
digital detailed you I feel better my
heart feels better my head feels better
I know this is a little corny but I I
genuinely do feel that way and I was
also just making me want to reinvest in
everything I'm doing that's why we have
a new set now and a new website and all
this it's like I really like I believe
in this thing and I want to sort of take
now these pieces that I just absorbed of
the world over the last month and now
apply them to all this stuff like you're
so calm and your talk about time Shapiro
and now I'm going to take a bunch of
torture okay here let's go to work my
friend mmm-hmm I mean this is the you
know you were promised a tsunami of news
and so it shall be so alright so I knew
of the story yeah
what was the last thing that you saw in
the news okay let's go over Lebanon so
the last thing that I know of was the
day that I got off the shut down
everything the last thing that I heard
was that the New York Times hired that
writer the the female Asian writer and
apparently she had tweeted a lot of anti
white rain so Jon yeah yeah so I know
nothing print for all I know she doesn't
have a job now she does have a job she
has a big job than ever she show on CNN
she has a job so she hasn't got to see
at right and there was blowback on
anyone who suggested that she was a
racist a lot of the left came out and
said that she couldn't be racist because
racism is actually discrimination plus
power yeah right so she she still has a
job yeah and that's totally okay let's
be very clear on this because I am
feeling clear minded yes right now
racism is hating someone because of
their race it has nothing to do with
power yeah that was my price you
couldn't be black and hate white people
in your racist you can be white and hate
Asian people in your racist and you can
be Asian and hate Latino people just
because of their skin color and you are
racist no not according to New York
Times is wrong right so that's the end
of that story
meanwhile Alex Jones got banned from
Facebook literally so she still has a
job there so so I saw a bunch of the
tweets the only one of the the one tweet
look I've joked you know before I sort
of woke up politically I used to joke
about Republicans be an old white man a
lot and whatever and it was just stupid
jokes
I don't regret them because it's just
part of what made me me sort of I think
they're stupid and they were
short-sighted and maybe not very
informed at that time but what one tweet
that I did see and I think this might
have been quite literally the last thing
I saw before I shut down was there was
something about she like hated she loves
making old white people cry yeah yeah
yeah and I thought that that kind of
strikes that kind of strikes me you know
so there was a big argument that took
place over Sarah Jean not just over her
actual comments but over whether she
should be fired based on Twitter mobbing
so there's a big sort of discussion that
happened about social media mobbing and
people piling on and whether people
ought to be fired and lose their jobs of
our old stuff that they've tweeted and
of course that followed in the wake of
the James Gunn's stuff which you were
still here for those Jim's gun from
guardians of the galaxy members brain so
that had just as I was getting off and I
mean exactly so James Gunn getting
Guardian the galaxy director he lost his
job because there were some old tweets
of his that were that were you know
making jokes about pedophilia and such
and so there was a lot of talk about
Twitter mobbing and then the Sarah's
young thing happened and that was a
Twitter mob and so there was a lot of
talk about whether not whether she
should have been hired which is a
separate conversation but whether people
should lose their jobs based on people
digging up crap you did ten years ago
and now coming after you so let me get
this straight so so she still has a job
justifies all that stuff Roseanne Barr
does not have a job right because of one
tweet which I actually do believe that
Roseanne didn't know that Valerie
Jarrett was black and Rose a crazy
person Roseanne is what she is right so
describe a crazy person right right well
depends which person you're talking to
but I just want to understand all this
if you're trying because when you step
away it does seem a little odd so
Roseanne sends this one tweet which she
apologized for said she didn't know that
she was back there's no reason to think
that Rosanna's a history of racism she's
always been fighting for left because
it's forever actually so she gets fired
from the number-one sitcom in the
country then this girl sorry one more
time John cuz I'm out of it a little bit
she she maintains her job she maintains
her job and gun his gun got fired yeah
gun got fired there was an attempt to
bring him back but that kind of failed
yeah turns out they're pictures of him
at some like joke pedophilia themed
party
with the women were overage but they're
dressed of schoolchildren and such so
Disney was not going to maintain his job
so I don't even know what to do with all
that but I think partly I guess and I
guess this is from stepping away for a
little bit it's just this sort of when
we apply the standard and certain that
that I think that's what's driving
people crazy probably mostly
conservatives and people on the right
yeah that seems to always weigh much
more heavily on you even learn one of
the facets of this the miss was so
Candace Owens then tweeted out
everything Sarah Jean had tweeted but
with reversing the races and Twitter
immediately suspended her before they
realized what she was doing
no sure they yeah that was good okay so
meanwhile Alex Jones gets banned from
Facebook and iTunes there's a
coordinated hit on Alex Jones between I
believe it was Facebook and YouTube and
iTunes to D monetize him and deny him
platforms Wow all in the same day
on the same day I think was within 48
hours so it's fun to break this stuff to
you and and Wow wait so just D
monetizing him no I think YouTube
actually took down his entire channel oh
wow Alex Jones is not on YouTube I
believe so I haven't checked recently
but yes that was the story and they all
did this on the same day within 48 hours
so it was it was obviously a coordinated
hit obviously coordinated it Wow and so
they took him down
they gave various reasons why but they
didn't give any sort of objective reason
why so it wasn't like some of them said
it was because he had threatened
violence in the past some of them said
that it was because he had said
unpalatable things in the past but there
was no clear standard and so there are a
lot of folks on the right saying listen
even if you don't like Alex Jones you
know people I said that I'm no Alex
Jones fan I mean threatened me
personally but but you got to at least
articulate a clear standard for how
you're gonna police the boundaries here
otherwise everybody ends up in the in
the throw them overboard category
because these boundaries are randomly
expanding so yeah Alex Jones got hit he
hasn't really paid any serious monetary
price because he has alternative
distribution channels right and he's and
he's insulated and but don't lose the
nice things you get a massive hit oh
yeah no I mean it's obviously took a
seriously although his listenership I'm
sure is up because people are tuning in
because so where do you stand on this
now because you know for the last two
years I've been saying relentlessly the
answer is not government intervention I
just don't think that the government
Leasing Facebook and YouTube writer and
all those things that that will help
anything I think it would muck things up
even worse it would give more power to
just middle management bureaucrats and
since the government's not very good at
anything I don't think would be very
good so President Trump is this is one
of the other stories president Trump has
sort of jumped into this and suggested
kill president he's still president
okay so congratulations CJ McIntyre you
didn't miss the big finale but he was
suggesting regulation some other
Republicans have sort of put it out
there I don't agree with regulation but
I do think that we're gonna have to come
up with either some market-based
solutions or we're going to have to you
know recognize and enforce Facebook and
Twitter to be treated as as not
platforms but as as actual publishers
which is the real controversy over over
Facebook is it a platformer is it a
publisher to like over a tail a wire
which I run if we print something that
is libelous we'll be sued yeah I mean
legally Lavis will be sued if Facebook
puts up an article by us that is
libelous then Facebook doesn't get sued
it's a platform if they're not policing
what can be put up and what cannot at
what point you start saying well you're
just like The Daily wire or the New York
Times or CNN and you start getting
police that way I think that Facebook
either needs to demonstrate you know
what its objective standards are or
start getting treated like any other
publisher
in the States because you're gonna
police and they're policemen yes so
you're right and you're being consistent
with I think what your other views are
in this department but there is this
piece of me that it's like did we miss
the boat in a weird way now that I've
stepped away for a bit like with the
amount of people that are watching Rogen
and watching you and me and the rest of
the unsanded ELC like why don't we have
a network already you know to be like I
know there's endless discussion yeah
I've had discussions about it we've met
with people I but it's almost there's
something it almost is like there's some
other weird thing here like the amount
of power that these companies have now
amassed over us is bizarre and it's like
if if the crew of us can't figure out
how to do it who can figure out how to
do it I don't know what the answer to
that is but it does I'm a little I mean
this is where of course I'm for the
market dictating it so it's like yet on
yeah yeah like let's get crackin because
at the end of the day look forget Jones
I
he's irrelevant I think in the scheme of
whatever it but it's like at the end of
the day you get rid of him well now
you've moved the bar it gets a there's a
lot of people that think that you're an
extremist oh by the way so I do want to
mention this real quick so one of the
there were a couple two or three little
things that were rattling in my head
about current events while I was away
and one of them was a few weeks before I
went offline was the mark Duplass thing
right here and it for some reason it was
really sticking with me while I was gone
because for those that don't remember
mark Duplass basically mark Duplass
who's a friend of mine who's been on the
show who is a lefty in it and a
extremely decent human seem like a nice
guy I had breakfast with him like two
weeks before the tweet was sent out he
is a really nice guy he's trying to
bridge the big the officers been hour
and a half together he seemed like a
nice guy yeah that's it he's just a nice
guy trying to do some nice work he
mostly does those comedy stuff so he
tweeted out basically that Ben Shapiro
isn't the devil that's it and basically
that people should take a look at you
write something like you're somebody
who's honest on the other side of the
aisle or something and yeah so this
happened a little bit before I went off
the grid when he deleted it then they
tweeted it analyst apology so the mob
comes after him
he then tweets this thing about how he
doesn't stand for homophobic or racist
views implying basically that you're
racist all the usual nonsense and I
don't want to make this about mark
because I think he's a good guy and I
don't know what pressure came to bear on
him either from studios or the mob and
it scares people you don't want to lose
your jaw texted him when he deleted the
tweet and I said I totally understand
why you do that I get it and then the
next morning he tweeted it dance but
that was really rattling in my head
because as I've stepped away it's like I
know and this goes to what I said
earlier we need these middle decent
people who are willing to figure some
things out and it's like they basically
took him out yeah like and when I say
they it's like who knows what that is is
it just the mob is it you know Studios I
don't know exactly what it is but like
those are the types of people that we
need and this is why I would link it
back to the Alex Jones thing yeah
they're trying Overton Window the
Overton Window will continue to shrink
it's like art we get where to Jones one
day and no one wants to defend Jones so
fine okay
he's gone but they'll keep moving it and
they'll keep saying that Shapiro's this
or Reubens that or whatever it is and
eventually eventually will being on the
outside of that thing too and that's
very much on my mind right okay so in
other news
Alexander Ocasio Cortez continues to
sort of gain the steam as this really as
she's gaining steam she continues to
gain sort of public prompt which made a
bunch of gaffes well your honor
she suggests that the middle class
doesn't exist anymore she suggested that
everybody in the country even though the
economic statistics are good that's only
karate has two jobs so he said okay and
and then there's a bit of a tiff because
I offered to host her on my show or
debate her oh right and I offered to
drop ten thousand bucks for the
privilege then she suggested I was cat
calling her so that was so that was her
response was that I was cat calling her
and then in their mainstream editorials
in the New York Times suggesting that it
was sexist for me to offer her no no
good times not a major story but Rove
the news cycle for probably a couple of
days so you I know you well enough you
offered to debate her would you offer to
debate her and the winner I don't want
yes I said whichever one you want I'm
happy to have you on the sunday special
which you've been on yeah for discussion
I've had on a bunch of people I disagree
with hate on Sam on that special yeah
I've had on Erica and special I've had
on a bunch of people with whom I
disagree on a variety of issues on that
special yeah and and I said I'll give
ten thousand dollars to charity or to
your campaign or a super PAC whatever
you want and or we could do debate
whichever format you choose
and she tweeted back that she that
there's no reason for her to respond to
this is the equivalent of men catcalling
women which is like I don't know how
they can home in equivalent of men
treating women equally that's what it is
right you're not viewing her you're not
going I want to talk to this woman
because she's a woman so I can destroy
her you're going this is somebody who I
disagree with or at least I want to
explore their ideas a little bit more
will do it either way you want
also cat calling in me weird weird move
so that so that was kind of a minor
store and I don't want to hover on that
one too much because juice nobody but it
does go to this sort of a bigger thing
that these people are put out there with
their ideas that all sound good all of
this I mean this is another thing that
was rattling in my brain a lot but all
of this leftist stuff that I used to buy
your for gays your for this your for
poor
people it's all [ __ ] it's all epic
endless horse [ __ ] I mean that really is
all it is you're not for gays you're you
know I mean it doesn't even make sense
to say you're for gays because gays
think differently that it's incredible
you'll never believe this you get ten
gays in a room they probably twelve
different opinions and to say that
you're for black people are you for
black conservatives I mean I know you
know this stuff but again when you step
away from it it's like be in a weird way
and I hate I really hate to do this but
in a weird way
Catharine burble Singh who is the last
guest I had on last week but we had
taped it at the end of July she's an
educator in England she had taught in
the inner cities for a long time and
basically realized that all these guilty
liberals were just kept throwing money
at things that were keeping minorities
oppressed and she said something that
really hit me and this is the last thing
that I did before I left she was
basically saying these people are the
racists they're the modern racists and
they're always screaming that we're all
the races and I don't want to become men
so I don't want to sit here and be like
oh you know these lefties are all the
racist bah-bah-bah but the the racist
ideas of the day are not coming from
conservatives and libertarians they're
really not and they're certainly not
coming from classical liberals they're
coming from the progressives that
actually is just true it just is okay
Shapiro keep going let's go okay so
let's do a bunch of Muller updates
because there was a bunch of news out of
Muller land but you've already told me
Trump is still president storm the
castle yet the the the latest generic
congressional ballot has Republicans
down I think it was the NBC ballot today
hasn't done 18 so do you buy that I buy
that Republicans are down I don't know I
don't think they're on 18 but I think
the Republicans have some serious
problems in the midterms the the the I
mean Democrats have a lot of motivation
to turnout and they have since the
election because they feel like if
they'd turned out they would want in the
last election which is true all right so
that's that's been building so here's
what happened I'm gonna bump these all
together there's a lot okay so Peter
struck got fired over at the over at the
DIA at the FBI so Peter struck is
everyone recalls is the guy who is
texting with his paramour Lisa Paige and
leading the rush investigation and the
Hillary investigation and he was fired
for
essentially sullying the reputation of
the FBI so he ended up being fired
president Trump revoked security
clearances for people like John Brennan
I oh yeah former CIA director there were
rumors that was gonna happen yes he did
daddy he revoked his security clearance
so what do you make of that because I
kind of I'm not a I'm not an
intelligence analyst at the highest
levels here but the idea that that
Brennan and some of these guys were
taking classified information and
clearly leaking it to the media or The
Times or whatever like forget what the
information was forget the Trump as
president if anyone was president and
former officials who still have
clearance which is also a little unclear
to me why as a former official when you
have a clear right so I guess the basic
idea is that a former official if I go
to you for advice I need to be asked to
be able to ask you about that stuff and
it's still a crime if you leak
classified information to the president
if you no longer work for the government
that said right so that's there there
shouldn't be you know in my opinion
there shouldn't be like a blanket
security clearance you get to maintain
after you leave office it seems silly to
me well it wasn't anyone else important
I'm sure Brennan was probably the
biggest brenda was the biggest one he
threatened to do it to Comey who I think
no longer has clearance and runs rather
basically what it looked like was a
coordinated political hit by Trump
because Trump then went on Twitter and
said like everybody I hate should no
longer have a security clearance and so
people said this is misuse of power
which of course President Trump doing
everything in the dumbest possible way
it sort of is
yeah but that said should these people
have security clearances probably not
that was the minor news in this in this
area I mean that that's huge in a
certain respect but here's the major
news the major news is that Michael Kahn
the president's former personal attorney
pled guilty to eight different crimes
including violation of campaign finance
law and in that plea of guilty for
violation of campaign finance lines the
red wedding part he suggested that the
President of the United States ordered
him to violate campaign finance law so
ordered him before he was president so
just as way so the so here's what
happened he goes to pay off his stormy
Daniels the basically David pecker over
at the National Inquirer the idea was
that this was a campaign finance
contribution that he had bought the
story of stormy Daniels from the
National Enquirer in order to silence it
pecker gon bought storms getting a story
and then team from buys the story from
David pecker reimburses pecker
or the story money was that so it was
Kohn's money yeah so it looks like a it
looks like a campaign contribution and
then trump back fills the amount of
money that cohen paid over the course of
coming months right now the question is
whether Trump knew that he was violating
campaign finance law when he did that so
in other words he there are two ways he
could have just legally speaking there
are two ways that he could have avoided
this being a campaign finance violations
could have flat-out written the check
well collect Lee and then you'd have had
to report it as a campaign expenditure
presumably why could he write it why a
campaign expenditure why couldn't have
just written the check so he can know he
can write but he has to report that to
the FEC
right or he can have Michael Cohen write
a check well he he would have to have he
would have to do it personally or he'd
have to show that he basically used Cohn
as a pass-through and then reported to
the FEC but there was no report to the
FEC brenson basically the idea was that
they found a back-channel to pay her off
just so it wouldn't be reported a week
before the election and so the idea is
that he was essentially avoiding the
reporting of the stormy Daniels thing
will week before the election by paying
off a porn star that's and Michael Cohen
was saying that Trump knew all of this
and Trump ordered all of this yeah and
that's why he did all of this so how are
we supposed to get any truth out of this
this is the type of thing where it's
like again stepping away it's like all
right we can do all the little legal
loopholes the little my new show and
look back on two years ago and who did
this and that but it's like Michael
Cohen probably wants to save his butt
now from certain amount of jail time
he's going to do whatever he can
obviously to throw Trump under the bus I
have no doubt that Trump probably did
some things out more out of just like
bravado and stupidity than like
intention like do you think he really
was like the crime that they're gonna
get Trump on was that $250,000 payout to
a porn star like how stupid is this
whole thing why is it so in there are
two ways in which Trump could defend
himself one he could say listen my path
ladies all the time so this isn't a
campaign expenditure at all this is just
me paying off ladies you know is there
any history of Michael Cohen doing this
for him before so there's there's a
history of Michael Cohen kind of
threatening people oh yeah but we
haven't seen evidence that he's like
paid off a bunch of ladies before yeah
and the other thing that Trump
theoretically could do to avoid all of
this is you could say well Michael cones
the lawyer I didn't tell him to violate
campaign finance law it's his job to
make sure that I've been compliant with
campaign finance law I'm an idiot
yeah what do I know about campaign
finance alai just said Michael go settle
this thing I mean that's the Hillary
email excuse right right right right I'm
an idiot and it's not implausible right
that's that's a plausible defense that
said his personal lawyer is testifying
in open court that Trump told them to
violate campaign finance law does that
mean Trump gets prosecuted I asked you
at the former president you can't
prosecute the current President of the
United States just legally speaking in
all likelihood but will that be a ground
zero for any impeachment charge I'm sure
that it will be the same day that
happened by the way because we're all of
you TV show the same thing that happened
Paul Manafort is for my campaign manager
also pled guilty to eight felonies none
of them having to do with campaign Trump
but having to do with former campaign
finance violations in representing the
Ukrainian government and all of this
kind of stuff and then Trump starts
tweeting about how mana for it's a good
guy because he kept his mouth shut which
is because President Trump has diarrhea
of the of the Twitter well first of
office oh wait so Cohen's going in there
and saying Trump told him to violate
camp fire I mean that sounds actually
insane so if that's actually true like
if Trump actually sat him down was like
here's the check let's violate some
campaign fight it's like now we're
veering into like like impossible well
it's it's but it depends how much
plausible deniability you need right if
Trump said here's a check for $130,000
go settle this up and Cohen said to him
what we need to report that to the FEC
he said well let's do cash right then
you've got a problem but yeah we have to
see what that looks like and it hasn't
been taken that level yet the SD NY is
still checking into that and what are
you so a guy that's doing your show
every and talking about this stuff every
day I know you research thoroughly all
of that how do you find the ability to
talk about the ins and outs honestly
without without giving enough room where
people are just gonna guess on all of
these that means that's not gonna be put
on CNN that's right I mean on CNN it's
he violated campaign finance law this is
a this is a federal violation he should
go to jail yeah and the answer is well
that depends on the credibility of Cohn
it depends on Trump's defense it depends
on a lot of stuff Trump doesn't help
himself because he goes on Twitter and
just says [ __ ] right I mean that's his
thing but it doesn't that I have not
seen the Trump tweet in a month well
good for leader difference that's that's
a that's a daily relief I'm sure of 34
[ __ ]
well I mean get ready man is there some
more coming that was it so that was the
big story because now that is that story
right that's two weeks old so it's like
is it already running out of steam I
mean everything kind of although you
know maybe it's contributing to the
Congressional ballot for example because
it feels like there's a level of
corruption that is being exacerbated by
another political story which is to
Republican Congress people are being
prosecuted for corruption right now
Duncan Hunter down in SoCal and in San
Diego he's being also prosecuted for
looking like he basically took a bunch
of campaign finance campaign funds and
use them on personal expenditures and
Chris Collins over in New York who these
were the first two congressional
candidates who back Trump and Collins
came forth and and supposedly was
engaged in some sort of insider trading
deal so both of them are now gonna be
prosecuted by the Sessions DOJ which is
my President Trump to attack Jeff
Sessions at the DOJ and literally this
morning tweet out that or last night
tweet out that that Jeff Sessions is
killing Republican congressional chances
by indicted Republican Congress people
so that's all what the president he has
his right to free speech he's gonna end
up probably screwing himself over with
all of that like when I'm hearing this
it's like man this is all just a great
reason to ultimately be a libertarian
like no it seems like none of this wars
right none of this actually works like
if it all worked if there was a slim
trim operating government that didn't
have too much power and could just move
things on the margin and not try to
redistribute and all of these things
it's like and it worked and it wasn't
always all government does is
investigate itself all it does is throw
money at things like it doesn't do
anything so all of these things as
you're telling me I know these are
important relevant things and when I
fully dive back in like in six months
they may not be and then two weeks they
may not be because but at least
understanding the issues behind their
importance but like this this general
thing of like oh this guy campaign
finance this guy that this is all they
do this is all they do and if you think
Democrats are somehow better than
Republicans you're wrong they're all
doing it together some sort of grouping
these into political and then we'll do
some and then there's a bunch of
cultural stuff it's gonna happen so yeah
other political stuff the Cavanaugh
hearing is happening literally as we
speak
right now
the Democrats tried to shut down the
hearing from the beginning by calling
for an adjournment until they could read
the documents even the vote they've
already come out and said they're not
voting for Cavanaugh Linda Sarsour got
arrested because she showed up and
started yelling at at Cavanaugh and at
the Republicans and so it kind of
devolved into the spectacle we all knew
that that would be you know in the
spirit of my 34 days off the grid I'm
not gonna say a word about Linda so
therefore you did that is that is some
inner peace pause though so there's
nothing they can do to stop cab that's
what happen you know you can for the
record people can find this video
somewhere but when I was on TYT way back
when and and Harry Reid used the nuclear
option and I was still progressive lefty
liberal blah blah blah I said this is a
bad move this is a bad move you do not
want to give this kind of power because
it'll be used against you so and a bad
move it was so there there are two and
had Trump books that have come out the
first was from Palmer no semantics all
the media went nuts over this she's she
had recordings she had taken her cell
phone into like throughout the West Wing
and recorded a bunch of conversations
pretty much everyone is that illegal
um maybe maybe there was nothing
classified on the recordings okay it's
basically she had nothing to sell and
she sold whatever she had yeah but it
was non-stop on cable news for 24 hours
a day for a week
and maybe two weeks for shooting that
I'm saying and then yeah then he and
then he tweeted out that that Omarosa
was fired like a dog and was something
like that and what's the cause her dog
better than its improving grammar but
when once called her dog then it turned
into is Trump a racist because he called
her a dog even though he is called half
of humanity members of the canine
species so so we enjoyed two weeks of
along semantics dog is actually an
upgrade over what do you what I think
opposed humans at the moment that's
exactly right and then Bob Woodward's
book comes out this week and there are a
bunch of sort of typical trumpian
stories John Kelly saying this place is
miserable the work and James Madison
Trump is basically a nut who wanted to
pull completely out of South Korea and
asked for pre-emptive military options
against North Korea and various and and
I think was Gary cone like sneaking
documents off of from desk so he
wouldn't sign them interim not notice
all the things that you would
back to in the white house so all that's
coming out in Woodward's book so expect
Trump to tweet about that a lot this
week and then we get to some of the
cultural issues so at the VMAs bunch of
stars bash Trump no shock but wait a
minute wait a minute you're telling me
Hollywood people at an awards show were
anti Trump I know shocker that's a big
one this changes everything
Asia Argento is a leader in the me to
movement was implicated in in her own me
to scandal well so there's a 17 year old
boy who had once played her son in a
movie I guess and when he was 17 and she
was 30 38 I believe they went to a hotel
room she snubbed him and a parent and
which is statutory rape in the state of
California and he and he said that
basically been intimidated into it and
she was hit with this me to stuff also
and then Rose McGowan came out and said
we should wait until all the evidences
in which provided all sorts of fodder
for people who say you know maybe we
ought to wait for all the evidence to
come in so it's interesting
now that it's turning on on its own
people now we should wait right like
right Trudeau was like we have to
believe all women then it came for him
now we have to wait it comes for one of
them me two people now we have to wait
so this is a bizarre so that happens and
and Sarsour she was part of me too so
this is this is a bad yeah there's also
a story with mentioning is a New York
University professor who is like a
performance artist who is a lesbian but
she was accused of sexually harassing a
gay man and it's relatively credible her
lesbian was sexually harassing a gay man
she's not a very good lesbian I think
that she's exactly she's bad bad at the
lesbianism so it's said that that and
the entire Academy came out to defend
her of course because she's of the left
and that's the way this works but how
was it lesbian sexually harassing again
I mean she was sending him sexual
messages I mean they have the text
messages so again not good at the
husband I think how stupid this whole
thing is I mean look look of course
you've got to get the bad guys though
the Harvey Weinstein's of course the
people that genuinely do the bad things
that you have to get them but the thing
that we're creating here where people
are gonna be afraid of their own shadows
and you know we're in LA here I have a
friend who's been in in the battle on to
give away too much who's been in the biz
on the other side of the camera for a
long time who's a white male in his
probably late 50s he's done extremely
good work for a long time he's worked on
a million TV
shows that you know well he's now you
know the way it works with these shows
is you usually work a season or two and
then you move on to something else or
huge gaps in between seasons or what or
sometimes you just work for a studio and
they throw you in all these different
places he's telling me now that he's
being told by executives that as a white
male as a straight white male that
basically he should either start looking
for other work or just don't expect to
work anymore
I mean think how actually dangerous that
is like dangerous is hoping with this is
a good decent man who has worked his
whole life who's an extremely
professional competent person but even
if he was completely incompetent right
should not hire him for incompetence but
not hire no don't not hire him because I
mean Henry Cavill I mean I think this is
before he left you remember Henry Cavill
said about dating I was having that he's
only gonna date women you know it was
because he's afraid that he's gonna get
caught in a me-too situation just
because he's rich and famous yeah he got
killed for that and I don't blame him
for that I mean honestly I can't blame
somebody like if you're famous and you
have money drj like the pence rule works
well for everybody right pence rule like
but one other thing on this you know
they also don't realize how backwards
this is actually gonna work because so
for example I was just telling you we
just hired a new full-time of here so I
have a new assistant Helen who's
wonderful and when we were hiring it did
pop in my brain for a second but I would
not want to hire a gay man I don't want
to not because I'm gonna harass them I'm
not going to harass them but why would I
hire someone who might one day turn on
me and then be like Dave harassed me now
I happened to be gay so it seems that I
may if I was gonna harass someone it
would be a gay man right I guess it
could be a straight man 2 or whatever
but it's like you know so in a weird way
and it's like you working woman and she
doesn't mean she literally work oh my
dad stay at home and I remember when I
was young she said if ever you have an
assistant hire like a blue haired old
lady yeah specifically it's like 20
years looking for ya all right so let's
see what else happened while you were
out oh well okay so this was this was a
big controversy Somali Tibbets was a 20
year old Iowan student at university of
iowa and she was kidnapped and murdered
by a guy who turned out to be an illegal
immigrant and this became a major cause
celeb because president
meant about it talking specifically
about border policy a lot of people on
the right jumped on it specifically
about where was it as in Iowa okay and
the and the left suggestion of course
had nothing to do with the illegal
immigration it was bad to talk about it
we should never talk about this sort of
thing you know the same left that says
every time there's a mass shooting we
have to talk about gun control now they
say when it comes to this you can't talk
about illegal immigration President
Trump tweeted incessantly about it he
cut a bunch of videos like from the
White House lawn talking about it and
this became kind of political fodder the
family said like we don't want any part
of this please don't politicize it she
was on the left her families on the left
and they it turned into a bit of a
brouhaha yeah so where are we at with
this now like I mean the investigation
of the guy has been arrested he's gonna
go to jail presumably but the sort of
battle is less over what happened in the
case and more over the politicization of
particular situations like should we be
talking about broad-based policy based
on individual circumstances is it
cynical to do so when is it appropriate
to do so so it sort of generated that
conversation yeah I mean this is one of
the ones where it's like this is exactly
why I do this show to talk about ideas
and not every little instance of a thing
that happens now of course this this
sounds absolutely horrific but the way
like one thing that I really don't miss
after being away is like the three days
that everyone cares and then we don't
care net neutrality is going to destroy
the world we scream about it for three
days then we forget about it children
being separated we scream about it for
three days and it's also like everyone's
screaming not doing all the people that
or even get the people that are getting
twenty thousand retweets on all the
things that they're tweeting out it's
like are you doing anything about it now
I get it it's important to share your
thoughts and to talk but one of the
things that I really want to do over the
course of the next year is figure out
how do we put some of this stuff into
action because all we do is go from one
crisis to another we pick this it gets
politicized by Trump for immigration
purposes it gets politicized for the
other guys for open borders or whatever
it is and it's like nothing got better
after that actually we just we just kick
the can down the road to hell like that
so have a couple more kind of minor ones
and then there are a couple major ones
to finish up on the other minor ones Ron
de santis candidate in Florida so he won
his gubernatorial primary okay
the guy who ran against him if you won
the primary on
as gonna Mandarin Gilliam who's black
guy and when DeSantis he did an
interview very early on talking about
how Gilliam was a good candidate who had
debated folks and he said you know we
have a good economy now we don't need
the guy who's a socialist because
Gilliam is very far to the left
you know he says we don't need somebody
who's a socialist to come in and so and
sort of monkey things up for for the
state of Florida and this became a 48
hour news cycle in which the Santos was
accused of being a racist for using the
phrase monkey it up in regards to
socialism screwing with the capitalist
economy but he'd used the phrase monkey
as a verb and therefore he was obviously
race baiting and dog whistling - the
evil racists who now are going to
realize Andrew gillum's a black man
right so allow me play this simple son
to my Jewish friend here is there any
evidence that he's an actual racist
beyond this comment okay
so this is like remember when Howard
Cosell it's a little before our time but
Howard Cosell got fired I think by CBS
News because during a football game even
though he was the thought of really is
the greatest sports broadcaster of a
generation he said there was a black it
happened to be a black football player I
like running back or uh I think was a
running back jumped over a guy and he
said something about like he's monkeying
over him or something like that and
everyone started calling him racist now
this is well before our days of now
everybody's a racist and he got fired
because that it turned out that that's
what he called his grandchildren all the
time if I'm remembering the story
quickly he was always saying oh your
monkeys your jumping all over each other
and blah blah blah so this thing about a
word and that if we can get you on a
word we now know what your hole is
because it's not only your political
ethos that we know what your whole
humanity is man that is that is so
dangerous
everyone has mocked up a word every now
and again and that you know everyone's
intentions all the time I mean this is
one of the things that when when sam
harris was first getting attacked
relentlessly by the left it was like
they always would go after the way he
they would be at OU he said that word
that way or we said this word but you
know you if you would have put a comma
there and it's like man you guys you
want to live in a world where we will
all be afraid to speak because we will
all get to the point where i mean again
it gets back to where we started but all
the good people will check out you will
never want to have a political
conversation with anyone the the areas
for us to just be human I know you've
talked about this a little bit to just
be okay
it's why I can't watch SportsCenter
anymore so we get to okay here's the big
story so yesterday
Nike released its new ad campaign the 30
year anniversary of just do it its face
Colin Kaepernick and its slogan believe
in something even if it means
sacrificing everything hashtag just do
it so he's the new face he hasn't played
in the NFL for two years no he is he
obviously is famous for kneeling for the
flag but apparently he sacrificed
everything he's he's gonna get multi
million dollars and his own line of
clothes in in the Nike brand of course
is create a great consternation so
that's that's the big story the last 24
hours I mean does this just prove and I
think a few other people I think what's
his name and I'm blanking I'll get out
that in a second that this social
justice thing just ruins everything like
it really did ruin ESPN yep and that
every time they translate ran so quick
that's that's really how removed I am
the second I can't remember friend's
name that it just ruins everything that
that you're handing out Sportsman of the
Year awards to Caitlyn Jenner and you're
doing all of these things in the idea
that you're being tolerant and good and
you're actually doing nothing that has
anything to do with what your mission
statement is what is Nikes mission
statement it's to put shoes and I guess
you know sports shirts on people so they
can be the best athletes they can be and
I'm not saying they should be completely
apolitical like they should and again
they can do whatever they want it's a
capitalist move then and if you look at
the statistics why they're doing this
whatever because this is know this will
drive first of all it's viral marketing
second of all Nielsen shows that the
people who are most likely to engage in
viral marketing on behalf of brands are
actually black folks in the United
States yeah they're 44% more likely I
think according to Nielsen and black
folks in the United States are also
significantly more likely to be buying
clothing as then then non-white folks in
the United States according to study
from University of Chicago buy clothing
expensive clothing okay Dabangg per
income level become level and there's an
interesting something to talk about
yeah they've done Studies on it's really
interesting yeah I and you know is that
a legacy of what theories on that is
that it's a legacy of if you can't
afford to show how rich you are by
buying an expensive car instead you buy
an expensive pair of shoes and it's 300
bucks as opposed to $35,000 for though
but it's it but there's there's a lot
there and obviously in terms of
disproportion and sports watching young
black men watch a lot more sports than
people of other races so it makes a fair
bit of marketing sense but the funny
part is the left falling into the trap
of now backing a massive international
company yeah right that is most famous
for running sweatshops in Asia that's
basically the story but it's also
obviously happening because Trump's
president right now this happened two
years ago if Hillary Clinton were
president they would not be doing this
with Colin Kaepernick yeah it's so
interesting so last night it was my last
night right and I have again I know
you're sad we've almost officially
ruined your life I think I think you
have a chance to ruin it a little bit no
but this is what it's all about right
this is why I got off the band this is
why this is why I want to do this with
you but but so the only thing that I did
do so it's not that I watched no TV but
I watch movies all right watch Netflix
or whatever so last night I watched
Avengers infinity war I hadn't seen it
before I thought the movie was
spectacular basically I'm sure you've
written a prolly you're probably written
a critique of it I don't want to go to
my only critique that was we all know
they're not dead so what the eff that's
exactly no spider-man didn't just die
but okay AA black panther there
$1,000,000,000
right it's a little property investment
completely right but putting that aside
I thought it was a pretty great movie in
the way they could link everything
that's the way I link this back to what
we're talking about right now is so Mark
Ruffalo who plays the Hulk in it he's a
huge lefty progressive whatever and he's
babbling on politics all the time and on
Twitter and whatever not I you know I
don't like attacking people so I don't
really want to make this about him but I
think he's a pretty bad actor in general
like I find him he very irritating as
the Hulk I thought Edward Norton was a
lot better in the in the previous
incarnation but after being away from
everything for a while watching him
knowing that here's this guy that like
really like politically I just think is
just so annoying and gets all these
retweets on like stupid stuff and just
shares all these what I
really bad ideas and whatever and of
course he can do it but like I was every
scene that he was in I was like like it
actually kind of learned for you yeah
like and and then David said something
which was interesting he was like he's
like it's you know actors of course they
could do whatever they want but it's
like if these guys would just shut up
and you didn't know anything about them
then they'd be doing their craft
properly you know like and I think
there's probably like people that do
that that really avoids was the studio
theory for literally died so it's keep
their personal life away from the papers
and just the only thing you see on the
screen is the person on the screen yeah
or some of them could be more famous for
something like like a Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie like there's like a
there's like a set even there you see
how his career like took hits in ups and
downs cuz of Brad Pitt and Jennifer
Aniston and then the Jolie stuff you
know he's now with Jolie and all the
skins right but like these open but
that's more about their relationships
and whatever yeah so that's one thing
but these overtly political people all
the time especially you know I haven't
thought about any of these people in a
long time but a lot of the comedians
that I used to like that have now gone
off the deep end politically it's like
you guys have ruined what I thought of
your comedy because of the way you act
and behave all the time aside no Luke
hey Louie CK is back whoo [ __ ] in
getting--getting crap for it what do you
mean back he performed at a stand-up
Club okay that would be the natural way
to start and people he got a standing O
but people on the Left were very very
very upset because he's not allowed to
come back yet because he hasn't served
his proper penance Wow
so what so for a guy like you so we're
conservative I know obviously the
actions that he did I'm sure you find
reprehensible and all that but I know
you do believe in forgiveness and I also
think there I also think that there are
levels of reprehensible so I think that
what he did is pretty reprehensible but
what he did is not in the Harvey
Weinstein category of reprehensive mhmmm
from from what I can see right so would
you argue then that a guy like Harvey
Weinstein there's no I know he's
probably not getting it natural rapist
right yeah these an alleged actual
rapist nobody's alleging actual rape
against Louie CK
right they're arguing that he brought
women into his room and then jacked off
in front of them right and then people
it was a jacked off but you won't say
[ __ ] on camera that's that's your policy
and I loosened personally all my
policies are mine your show it's your
show so I curse a little bit yeah I was
a kid on your shot once revived
you won't say [ __ ] you'll say [ __ ] right
exactly it's like this it's like Network
TV so it's but I yeah I think that you
know if there's a market for him to come
back there's a market for him to come
back I mean that's that's my general
feeling for this and if people want to
sue him then they should sue him and if
people want to like this is how this is
why we have a system of torts this is
why we have a system I mean he
apologized for presumably these women if
they think that they can find evidence
that they were actively denied jobs
because of Lucy kid it consumed you can
go 20 right exactly yeah but this idea
that we're gonna put people into kind of
excommunication until they come back and
then we again it's this variable
excommunication right if you're if
you're Mel Gibson it's a certain amount
of time and bck it's a certain amount
I'm Lucy Cates like eight months and for
Mel Gibson it's like eight years and
then eventually you come back and
daddy's home or something I find the
somatic fields by the way okay but
there's something interesting there
because it's like if you don't like
louis c.k let's say you don't like the
music if you don't like them as a comic
don't go to a show it seemed like it was
a person don't go to a show is if you
don't like what he did don't go to a
show right watch any of it don't appear
don't give him two drinks and the cover
charge all that just don't do it but
this is so fundamentally why I believe
that live and let live is the only way
to actually have a functioning society
but all you can do is defend our ability
to be different that's basically it
because otherwise because that should
the man never be allowed to work again I
mean they say a lot of people say yes
right okay so should his wife be allowed
to work should his children I mean it's
like this is this is sort of like as
when is repentance actually take place
be President Bill Clinton is still held
in widest statement for doing a lot
worse than then Louie CK that's like the
crazy well they until we'll get to that
yeah yeah here's it so there's we have
more headlines saying okay so heavily
number one is a retha Franklin died so
that was a really yes that's a big story
and she had a huge funeral it was a
10-hour funeral I believe something like
that it was really insane and they just
got like every great singer to play yeah
they got a bunch of singers in there and
the the kind of headline the politically
oriented headlines
al Sharpton got up in bash Trump and
then there was a and then Bill Clinton
was sitting on stage next to in order to
his who had been to his right so it was
Jesse Jackson al Sharpton
louis farrakhan yeah sitting sitting
next up all three of them
so that was one Clinton related have on
the other Clinton related headline was
more humorous which was Clinton who is a
dirty old man was a dirty old man when
he was a dirty young man ariana grande
sang and when she came up there was
video of him legitimately checking her
alley up and down full-on smiling
giggling like like really going after it
I mean you find you somebody who looks
at you the way Bill Clinton okay so
let's let's pause on that one because we
all know Bill Clinton like sweats go to
the other one forget Jesse Jackson
obviously and forget Al Sharpton
whatever forget that they're both both
anti-semites but the lesser of a
anti-semites they're you know I think if
Jews have learned one thing over the
millennia it's kind of like you got to
pick the big anti-semite to do whatever
but like what he was onstage to two or
three seats away from Louis Farrakhan
yeah after this is too I mean only was a
lot only two or three months ago those
insane
tweets about Jews being the devil and
all that yeah so he was it's a is there
and then that was juxtaposed with wait
wait was there any so of course
conservative media called him out nobody
else cared so nothing you probably don't
even make it on NBC Nightly News I know
it was sort of just seen as part of
thing you know they're all the funeral
together this is the [ __ ] that
people can't take anymore this double
standard epic nonsense that every time a
trump supporter does something everyone
on the right should apologize or
whatever and that this type of [ __ ]
the ex-president sits with what I would
argue is the probably the foremost a
preeminent anti Democrats that's
probably too right but like legitimately
like a disgusting human being who would
but by choosing to group up any group of
people in a specific way is the very
definition of prejudice and racism and
all that this is what the left is
supposed to be against this is their
whole thing but that's what was going on
so that was trucks plows what that
happened on the same day as the other
big story was that John McCain died so
that was not insure the one that you
heard it okay so this is the one that I
didn't know this until about two days
ago and I was on the phone my dad and I
said I said you know we were talking
about being off the grid and I said you
know and I have I don't know anything
and he was as if he just like I don't
know what happened selfie but he goes
but you know John McCain died and I was
like so they but did you know
also I know I know nothing other than he
dies so first off well I don't even know
when he died so just fires week and a
half ago we can oh he died to Saturday
before last okay so I think Sam and I
came back from Sabbath and that was the
news so so he passed away President
Trump obviously not a fan and the first
thing that so Trump didn't issue any
official statement for two days and then
he the the basic rule of thumb is that
when a sitting senator dies you lower
the the flags to half staff until the
person is actually buried Trump did the
statutory minimum he lowered the flag
for 24 hours and then he raised it back
up again all the other federal flags
were lower but you could see a picture
over the White House of the flag back up
at full staff and then after Washington
Monument you can see behind it you see
all of them down at half-staff he then
reversed himself lowered the flag again
issued a statement and then at McCain's
funeral he was not invited because
McCain didn't want on there which I
can't really blame McCain for that and
then at the funeral george w spoke Obama
spoke Megan McCain spoke all three of
them took shots at Trump so Megan McCain
so Megan McCain said we didn't need to
make America great again America was
already great and kind of really went
hard after Trump and then Obama got up
and he said our country was about all
these things he'll we couldn't the
American creed and we can and we're all
part of the same America and taking
pretty obvious veiled shots at Trump and
then Bush did some of the same sort of
stuff Wow
so that was it that was yesterday so a
couple things there first off on the
flag thing I mean this is the tight look
you know I think I've been pretty
freaking fair on Trump and I get a ton
of [ __ ] for it I think you've been
pretty fair on him you get at ownership
for it this type of thing like this flag
thing that's just like the none is
childish that's just that all this
nonsense that looks like this should not
be it just should not be this is this is
ridiculous so let's just move past that
one that's it
first off just quickly on Megan McCain
you know I got to tell you I know Megan
a little bit yeah we've met a couple of
times and I you know there's a there's a
clip of her about it probably about six
years ago if not more at this point on
real time did you ever see this where
she says something she's in she gets in
an argument Paul Begala is he a
democratic strategist yes is on the
other side and they get into an argument
and
she says oh you're just attacking me
because I'm young and I don't know
everything about World War two or
something he's like I wasn't alive
during the French Revolution but I know
about that and it gets huge applause and
it's a great line and it's like you
can't use your right use of them if
you're if you're a pundit or whatever
then then be a pundit you can't the
second you know it gets hot in the
kitchen you can't be like well I'm young
I'm not supposed to be here so that's
why I was very unimpressed that was the
first time I probably ever saw her
publicly and I was very unimpressed with
her I've gotten to know her a little bit
and I've watched some clips on the view
and my mom keeps calling me and telling
me that she's the same conservative yeah
and I gotta tell you I'm very impressed
by her I used to be very much at odds
and in the last I'd say year-and-a-half
we become at least friends that's
because of this I mean I think that
she's shifted yeah we've all shifted
since we were young but I think that
she's shifted to wait let me ask
something so I assume that the day he
died that there was the endless like
people dancing on his grave
there was some of that but mostly the
left was praising him because he was the
anti-drip right so is it so after
spending most of his life crapping all
over him right the guy's racist when he
ran for president and incompetent and
old and right exactly then he was a
great hero because he was anti Trump and
so his entire life was defined by the
fact that he and Trump didn't get along
so there was a lot of that you know my
own take on this that was that the the
funeral while I understand Megan McCain
is a grieving daughter she has said over
she wants but that said is it a smile
let's say that you actively wants you
undercut President Trump let's say that
that's actually your goal your goal at
this funeral is that you want to is that
you you don't like what Trump stands for
and you want to undercut him almost the
worst thing you can do is get George W
Bush Barack Obama and Meghan McCain up
there bashing Trump and the reason for
that is because there is this what Trump
is a response to is a sense that they're
a bunch of elites who get together in
backrooms and party with each other and
then they pretend to disagree with each
other for the cameras but in reality the
truth which is kind of true right but in
reality their back slapping each other
and they're all best friends and their
civil and we all get along and and then
we court kind of the commoner is out
here we're like wait a second these
issues actually matter to me why do I
care about your Golf Club I don't care
about George HW being friends of Clinton
I want to know like who wins this
political argument because it affects me
right I don't care about like how you
guys get along and so it was this
feeling like there was a video that was
going around in George W handing
Michelle Obama
piece of Canyon it's like well this is
what politics used to be and I just
thinking no it didn't yeah I'm old
enough to remember when Barack Obama was
labeling george w bush essentially a war
criminal yeah
and so you're gonna do this whole trump
is a departure from everything that
politics has ever been it just felt
really disingenuous not because the
criticism of Trump was was uncalled for
because I think some of it is called for
but because it was creating this image
of politics that didn't exist and then
contrasting Trump with this image of
politics that's not actually real so
isn't that an interesting example of why
the 24 note hour news cycle or whatever
you call Twitter now or what 24-hour
news cycle sounds crazy we need somebody
else yeah
this hyperspeed insanity of why it
really it's it's a threat to our ability
to think clearly about things because
the very people who you hated eight
years ago all these no I'm not saying it
was warranted then yeah I regret I will
fight on other I've ever said this
puggly I regret not voting for McCain
I respect I I I think that we'd be in a
very different place right now and I
think he was I think he was though he
may be the last decent man that we had
running for a president at least for a
long time decent guy but yeah okay so if
you remember he always wanted to go high
very high level okay I mean he refused
to go with the Jeremiah Wright stuff he
called off his campaign in the last
month because of the economic collapse
okay so without commenting on Romney
specifically like I think by all by all
measures McCain for whatever his flaws
may be and maybe he was a little more of
a neocon than I would care for or
whatever else it is it's like if you
don't think he was a decent man who
really loved his country like you're
you're actually crazy and this goes to
when you demonize people to the enth
degree who don't deserve demonization
then you get the real demon and I'm not
even saying Trump is the real demon but
the way they flip history so it's like
you hated him forever and you you wanted
to destroy this guy forever now he hates
your new demon because you're always
finding new demons right so now we got a
new good-guy and it's like that's not
that's partly because we cannot remember
history anymore because we're slammed
with three-day news stories that you
know I said it's 24 hours a second but
it's really it's more like a three-day
thing we care for three days and then we
expunge you know and I think that that
now is becoming like the real threat
right now okay so
finally the story for you and this are
the one that really has ruined
everybody's day but you can run your
that's great so there's a big scandal
we don't have booze on the Fed anymore
yeah but yeah yeah
you're not gonna unwind for this one
it's so basically there was a big
scandal in Pennsylvania there was a
state attorney general report that
suggested over the course of 30 years
1,000 children had been molested by
Catholic priests and that these Khitan
that these priests had been men shuttled
around and then following on that
there's a guy named Archbishop Pagano
and he was the papal lynsee I believed
to the United States and he came forward
with an 11-page letter in which he
accused essentially the entire Vatican
hierarchy of being complicit in covering
up child molestation and child rape and
what he suggested was a growing within
his terms homosexual subculture in the
church which he mean by which he meant
that there was their particular
Cardinals who had been accused of
actually seducing seminarians and all of
this sort of thing yeah I don't mean to
sound glib here but how is this sort of
new so it's only new in that he is
accusing Pope Francis of actively
covering it up oh okay so he's saying
that there's a Cardinal anemic Eric who
was who was complicit who was apparently
accused of child molestation or at least
molestation of underage seminarians
basically and this and this guy
archbishop Pagano said Pope Francis not
only knew about it he reinstated
McCarrick then Benedict had basically
put the guy in in silence and prayer and
that Francis had brought the guy back
and made him a public figure again and
had done so with multiple other similar
figures and because Francis the
accusation is soft on homosexuality
inside the Catholic Church that's his
accusation pagano's and then by
extension soft on people who had been
molested seminarians and also happened
to be homosexual or practicing
homosexuality so so I okay so
conflated here so things been conflated
one is people are suggesting that the
reason that this is all happening is
because anti-gay feelings in the church
are leading people to go after Francis
or leading people to go after mckarrick
and that's a weird argument because
really what we should all be able to say
is that
a few things can be true one there's no
statistical linkage between
homosexuality and child molestation
obviously - that a disproportionate
number of the people who have been
molested inside the Catholic Church have
been young boys yeah which is also
towards four out of five and three that
any Pope who covers this crap up should
be criminally liable basically and the
media it's like Paterno
I mean exactly and then you know this
exists in pretty much every major
institution secular or religious there's
always an attempt to cover up sins
inside that particular institution this
is true for every religious institution
that I know about pretty sure it's true
for every institution education I don't
like schools like legitimately everybody
NC tried to cover up the whole you know
trying to take out burn anything that
was trying to be yeah so the so the but
the the part of this story the twist to
the story whether the part that's new is
not only that it's a Francis stayed
silent has refused to respond to any of
the allegations it's the allegations
been backed by a bunch of other
testimony bishops are basically going to
war with one another for the first time
in five hundred years like they're
openly criticizing each other and the
and I think the most shocking thing is
that the media are running full-scale
editorials attacking the quote-unquote
ultra conservative wing within the
Catholic Church for going after Francis
so the same media that back in 2003 was
going after John Paul - yeah and saying
and benedict and saying these guys are
responsible for all of this and they
should now they're defending francis
specifically because they think that
this is a conservative attempt to oust
franciscan francis the liberal pelvis so
okay so basically the media is trying to
he's because he's a little more Pro gay
so to speak whatever the hell that no
environmentalist generation and all this
stuff yeah so the media oddly is trying
to protect him man I mean this again it
goes to the thing of like we are enemies
will be our friends the second we need
them and then we'll throw them out and
well I mean this just sounds awful and
it's it's it's it's awful yeah I mean
it's like a five hundred years get it
could cause a 500-year skin schism in
the church like the worst schism in the
church since maybe the Protestant
Reformation because there's like an
entire wing of the church because you
can't impeach the Pope there's an entire
wing of the church going the Vatican
hierarchy covered this stuff up because
they
cover the stuff up and now he's being
defended by a bunch of people who aren't
real fond of Catholics in general
yeah but somehow have now found
enthusiasm for Pope Francis if you were
if you were Catholic and and you were a
real believer but obviously didn't stand
for any of this of course yeah let's
just say you're the average Catholic out
there who's a good decent person you
happen to be a believer I would assume
the way you believe in Judaism yeah okay
so let's say let's say you're that now
Judaism I know doesn't have a structure
like that yeah my feeling is any rabbit
I mean I'll see you in the Jewish
Community Center no Hooke Catholic
doctrine works we don't have papal
infallibility in Judaism yeah
any rabbi who's complicit in the
cover-up of child molestation should
immediately go to jail yeah I mean like
I have no tolerance for this kind of
[ __ ] and the fact that this is not
only been tolerated but forwarded by
certain members of the press is an
astonishing thing is the same people who
are giving spotlight and Oscar right
five years ago right right because it
was so important to uncover all this
stuff happening within the church and
now it's no got hands-off I mean France
is really important figure and the fact
that all these people are attacking him
we can't take it seriously for political
reasons we have to we have to suggest
that it's just a hit job against Francis
do you think there's like sort of like
this is just another extension of as
we've over the last couple years just
watched all of these institutions
crumble like we've watched mainstream
media crumble we're watching our
political institutions I don't know
they're quite crumbling but they're
they're 15 they're teetering certainly
was shifting in nature and also like the
legislative branch is basically becoming
a useless nothing as we write as work as
we're handing everything over to the
king another good reason to be for small
government either a classical liberal or
libertarian but that that this with the
church without without making it too
specifically about these specific things
that it's just another one of these
things that these giant institutions
that used to be able to control
narrative control gatekeeping and all of
that they actually cannot withstand
things anymore sort of I mean this is
where I've been sort of critical of the
internet and the way we're all behaving
on there but like truth does find a way
so then we watch these institutions try
to attack the people because the people
have a better essence of what the truth
is then the institution's am I getting
something that's exactly right and and
the fact that it's the most shocking
performance by the press that I've seen
including anything with regard to drunk
to shift Rhonda to shift on a dime and
start going well you know let's not
check out these allegations of child
molestation because we really like this
Pope it's like whoa that's the best
that's pretty amazing stuff and I'm
talking not I'm not talking at the
editorial boards I'm talk about
objective news coverage objective news
coverage there is a headline in the New
York Times that said Pope Francis takes
high road as conservatives pounced over
allegations of covering up sexual abuse
of seminarians and - it's it's it's
totally wild I mean I think we this is
just part and parcel with what we've
watched sort of happened to the New York
Times over the last couple years I mean
you know I've said this many times but
I'm pretty sure the New York Times
didn't cover Bret Weinstein and
evergreen once in the pages of the paper
but it did three or four editorials
about it you know they they constantly
do this type of thing where it's like
they're editorializing their entire
coverage often by what they're not
covering and we've so - watch this what
was an important institution I think for
a long time kind of crumble like that
and I this gets us back to that was
story xx this gets us back to Story one
where now you're gonna bring in people
to actually instead this is where when
people say Dave you attack the left too
much you don't attack the right it's
like the the right this isn't about
institutional power anymore at some at
some low Trump's the president I get it
but like the left has all this media
power and all everything else and you're
willingly bringing in people that truly
are racist or if without calling these
people specifically racist have have
terrible ideas and you're saying this is
this is part of what mainstream should
be so you're mainstreaming what what are
really radical ideas all right okay so
submit your questions for me and for
Dave on patreon and super chat right now
we're gonna take a quick break and then
we'll be right back with those questions
oh man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we're back at the Ben Shapiro
report now sorry Rupert I'm posting
today because Dave is just back and if
you missed it earlier we went through
all of the news so David's markedly more
depressed than he was an hour and a half
ago which makes me happy since I'm a
sadist so let's run a tight ship by the
way when I do the breaks in between the
interview and the live show it ends up
being like I always say we'll be back in
30 seconds it's like seven minutes you
were like well come on I mean we gotta
make money right so we've got patreon
questions and super chat questions yeah
so let's start with a patreon question
Dave do you think there is any turning
back from the politicization of
literally everything fun or is this the
new norm now I think for now it is the
new norm and I think that we have to get
through this and I think we can get
through it I'm telling you as I said to
you an hour ago
I spent the last month talking to real
people all over the place ray I would
literally on the street like if I just
sort of like say if I was just standing
there I just talked I was just talking
to me but I really felt like I could be
a little more connected to people people
don't want everything to be politicized
all the time they don't want why do you
watch sports it's not for politics why
do you watch The Avengers it's not for
politics why any most of the things you
do it's not for politics and the fact
that they let this creep into everything
so it's just another and when I say day
it's like there's this a morphism
as far as media but yeah and I don't
know that it's it's a you know a fully I
think there is some level of
coordination in different ways but like
I'm not saying there's like a group of
five guys sitting in a room like how do
we divide America and destroy everything
maybe there is I don't know but this
endless thing where we just are gonna
hate each other all the time and this is
why I've said it before but like this is
why I truly truly believe I believe it
now more than ever
identity politics is the biggest threat
that a free society has and it's
particularly our free society because
we've done the melting pot better than
have anybody we did a melting pot we did
it right we blended this thing right
everyone still wants to come here for a
better life all these celebrities that
always tweet they're gonna leave nobody
ever leaves and the same people who will
tell you what a racist evil patriarchal
homophobic transphobic Society America
is they're the same people who want open
borders because they want apparently
everyone to come in and share in the
Harz so I think it's truly it is a
threat but yes
I think we will get past it and the
reason I'm hopeful is because when we
look at all of the the mainstream media
that's peddling this stuff crumbling and
we look at the amount of people that are
listening to long-form conversations and
getting what their ideas are I mean when
I go to these Petersen things and people
come up to me and say you know I started
watching your show and then I saw
Shapiro on there and Harris and Peterson
and bah-bah-bah and I started thinking
about things differently and then I
bought Peterson's book and you know what
I stopped smoking weed or yeah yeah not
a lot you can say it's smoking weed is
bad based on this and and I so I really
believe that while you can't see it if
you just look at that online tear that
in reality I think there is something
incredibly good happening ok so here's a
super chat question for you let's see it
says love this one's interesting
love the two of you you both converted a
socialist into a libertarian
conservative awful Russian Shapiro will
you bake Rubin a wedding cake ok so I
mean my answer is I'm married already
but an adverse my anniversary last week
an anniversary cake would have been a
right so I so the answer is no and the
reason I won't is because as a religious
Jew I got I do not participate in
activities that I believe are sinful but
again we live in a free country and Dave
knows this he doesn have to care what I
think
yeah about sin and as long as I'm not
bothering Dave I don't see why it's a
problem yeah so it's a well I will I did
this Dave have a husband yeah I mean
like okay and are we friends yeah and
are we gonna go out to dinner sometime
in the near future
yeah but but there's a difference
between me just being friends with Dave
and me actively participating in an
event that I feel is religiously sinful
and I think this how most religious
Christians and most religious Jews feel
and while that's awkward yeah we're
still friends in spite of it which is
why we're friends well in spite of it
than a bad thing well look when I when I
did your interview show which by the way
I mean yeah you Jack the idea of an
interview show from me it's all right
but nobody but what you said that to me
and and I truly mean this like if you
think what I'm doing is sinful like I I
don't
it sounds glib but I don't care all
right and then this is my use you don't
have to every country like right like
that's the thing and it's like look look
there's a
or someone's gonna go we'll wait a
minute if you really think his marriage
is sinful or saying of course they'll
they'll maybe a place that in the nature
of our friendship may be that we can't
quite get to that I would be able to get
to with someone that didn't think for
sure that is very possible and and it
goes both ways right like I then look at
you and I go well why that's a kid you
don't want me teaching your kid about
the nature of family perhaps right I
mean like there's some rights but you're
probably a pretty good dad like you know
what I mean like but why is it that
we're able to do this and most people
can't do this that's what I'm curious
the home at night and we can have our
own lives I mean that's that's real and
I think part of friendship by the way is
that like we go home at night we just
have our own lives yeah I'm not married
to you right that's like my wife and I
have to agree on these issues you and I
don't have to agree on these issues and
for us to share a common space together
and that's really the important you
think your wife and you have to agree on
these on all of these issues or just the
sort of foundational and the
foundational ones but I do think that
you know how you raise your kids
religiously and and with regard to
things like sexual morality does
actually have to be at the root of how
you teach your kids yeah so if you have
deep if you have deep divisions with
your spouse on these issues I think that
and you're looking to build a family
anyway yeah then I think that these are
issues were building on a bad foundation
is a bad move so okay so if you wouldn't
bake me a cake that's okay and now
because it's 50/50 I can't bake you a
cake which Davidson I'm not chef and he
would have done it kosher for you you
owe me this close putting that aside you
can't have it's kosher cake now if we
were having an anniversary party would
you come if I was inviting all the crew
that we all know and we were just an
anniversary party we're just having a
party and and I'll even throw in some
kosher food for you to make sure you
don't have to bring your own yeah
obviously I'd have to think about it I'd
have to think about it in the same way
so that's interesting to me that's a
different thing well it not really
because again it's if you're a religious
person again take it from the religious
perspective that from the religious
perspective the question is are you
glorifying something that you think is
sinful yeah so this is a party for
something that you think was originally
sinful can you participate in that so
from a religious point of view that's an
actual serious moral question yeah what
I got to dinner with you the answer is
yes right because that's not actually
like let's celebrate something that I
feel that you're doing is sinful but I'd
have to I'd have to think about that
I mean a perfectly honest rate forward
as possible I want even so it's to see
that's so interesting to me because it's
like if I threw a regular party just
we're at that party at my house and all
the guys make you a cake that had
nothing to do with a gay wedding right
and I would go to a party with you that
has nothing to do with gay marriage we
do bake me a regular cake could I just
have a my baking socks I'll buy you one
I want to Pierre okay and then I'm gonna
crap I mean it's not gonna be good but
it's is that it'll be there all right
let's see there's a lot there you know
what this is what we'll keep talking
about forever and it's alright exactly
alright let's see
so been huge fan why do Asians
overwhelmingly support the left in spite
of their cultural values and how do we
change this also how are you explaining
it to your kids why it's wrong to I are
using religion or reason so the on the
first question why do Asians
overwhelmingly support collapse I think
that there is a misperception that is
bolstered by a Republican inability to
talk about issues of race which is that
you have to overcome the the basic
presumption that Republicans are evil
racists and once you get over that
presumption then people tend to vote
more conservative by right Thank You
genes might vote for their own economic
interests right and and for their own
you know a college education interests I
mean it's the left that's trying to ban
Asians from higher education in places
like Harvard but the right has a
reputation as being racist and it is not
forwarded by intemperate remarks from
the President of the United States on
these sorts of issues right and the
right also you know should be willing to
ignant I think that there's this weird
conversation about race that goes
something like this people on the Left
say there's been historic racism in
American society and people on the right
read that as what you're saying is
there's historic racism in American
society and that means you want
affirmative action right and some people
on the right go I really want to talk
about that and the people in less say
well you don't want to talk about that
because you're a racist because what
they read the right saying is I don't
want to talk about it at all because
you're racist when the conversation
really should go like this the left has
there's historic racism in American
society and go right and then the left
says and now I want a forum to actually
say no conversation about the actual
policy right but we conflate the
questions because we're all reading each
other's minds and that's a dangerous
game well it's interesting because one
of the things that people say to me all
the time when I when I do public
speaking events and talk to people after
they'll always say you know I was a huge
amount of people say to me I was a left
I was just like you I iced then evolved
sort of the way you did and I can't tell
you the amount of friends that I have
that now think I'm a racist because I
believe in low taxes or bla bla bla and
it's like the way they've been able to
conflate policy with racism is crazy
because they think the average lefty out
there and I'm just doing something broad
for the purposes of a conversation
thinks that if you say low taxes you
mean you don't want to give money to
poor people now that is actually true
but that doesn't mean it's racist you
think that there are better ways to help
poor people than just taking money from
some and giving it to others so they've
really there's an incredible trick that
they've pulled there that these are not
racist the amount of conservative and
libertarian college things that I go to
and all these things and I never read a
cyst or I'm meeting some pretty damn
shady races because I can't figure out
their races and they keep they keep
inviting me so all right let's see um on
that second question how am i explaining
to my kids why it's wrong to lie
religion or reason I mean the answer
typically is both right you say that God
doesn't want you lie because you are and
and why doesn't God want you to lie is
the reasonable question and the answer
is God doesn't want you to lie because
it is he is a fundamental disrespect of
another person as made in God's image I
think that virtually all of Western
civilization is built on one verse in
the Bible that human beings are made in
God's image and from their springs and
enormous amounts of good there are
things in religion that have brought
about an enormous amount of bad but that
is one aspect of religion that I don't
think you can get to simply through
scientific materialism but this is a Sam
Harris this is this is the Sam you Sam
Jordan wanted that's what it all
whittles down to that can science and
reason in your own consciousness get you
there at a human speaking of which
there's a patreon question for it says
Dave did you find out what they what the
dark enlightenment is but do you know
someone asked me about the dark
enlightenment once on a patreon feed and
I I think maybe somebody sent me some
info I honest I think I think basically
the idea the dark enlightenment for
those who are sort of unaware is that
what what you know Pinker will do is
he'll basically say all the good stuff
that I like from the Enlightenment is
the Enlightenment and everything else is
the counter and dark enlightenment is
basically well no Rousseau was part of
the Enlightenment too he just happened
to suck and so that's in so trying to
look at the downsides and the upsides of
the Enlightenment is actually a
worthwhile so this is sort of like
remember right before I left there were
a couple people like really attacking
the Enlightenment as this racist
movement so this is sort of that some of
that but also like there's a there's a
perspective on the Enlightenment that
basically says that the Enlightenment
move toward individual values and away
from it was simultaneously and move away
from virtue so if you look at sort of
more ancient philosophy ancient
philosophy says that your goal as a
human being is to act in accordance with
natural law natural law being the things
that that reason dictates essentially
this is sort of the Aristotelian yeah
natural law argument and then in the in
the sort of modern period people say
well but everybody has a different idea
of what's good for them so this
libertarian idea and so what we need is
limited institutions so that people can
do whatever they want it's the idea of
the dark enlightenment basically is that
if you take that libertarian ideal to
its extreme where there is no social
fabric that combines us any more than
you either end up with sort of this atom
ism where everybody is on their own
there's no shared sense of belonging and
those who know share sense of values and
on the other hand if you believe that
reason rules everything but that
individual human beings don't mean
anything then Marx is a part of this
enlightenment ideal to our reason is the
head and we all we have to do is
reorganize Society along the lines that
we see fit and we can create a better
man right so I mean underside of the
Enlightenment right I got it so so you
know that I obviously I mostly believe
in that libertarian idea oh you're nice
or milled i right so I believe in it
within the prism of I think that's how
human flourishing and human freedom will
expand the most not I I believe you have
to be left basically to your own ideas
but I don't want to live in Mad Max at
the same time and I understand right
this is where this is reacting in
critique right Patrick bean has a book
called wild liberalism failed and his
basic critique is that we erred too much
on the side of Liberty without an a
focus on the social fabric that if you
don't focus on the social fabric you
don't focus on virtue you only focus on
right well you'll end up with is a bunch
of people who are non virtuous who think
everything is they're right you know
it's funny I mean you know my thoughts
on most of these political issues and we
just spent the last hour and a half
talking a lot about virtue and a lot
about the social fabric so whatever that
is therefore it that's that's where I'm
at okay here's a patreon question let's
see hmm okay what if any success could
President Trump have where the media
would give him credit
without a backhand dilution or anything
else do you think there's anything from
canoe where the media would give them
credit not really I mean they've painted
it look they've painted him as Hitler I
mean I the first video that I did the
day after the election sitting in my
backyard I said you know the risk here
is that and I was even saying this
before the election if you keep calling
someone Hitler you can never acknowledge
when anything is good and that that will
keep pushing you further one way and
potentially pushing the other person the
other way or at least the supporters
that way you because you can't be like
oh well the economy is doing well good
for Hitler
everything that you do that's good is
actually worse for you is actually evil
and this is also where you get this sort
of a guy who I you know I agreed with
for most of my life why now have some
disagreements with but I had nothing but
respect for Bill Maher you know a couple
months ago when he was talking you know
cuz he has real Trump derangement
syndrome and he was saying this thing
about how if we if the economy has to
fail to get rid of this guy that's what
we need and it's like yeah that's easy
to say when you probably have a hundred
million bucks and I'm not Jeff I love
Bill Maher and I hope he'll sit in this
seat one day and I'll not be there and
you you know late yeah yeah but you were
on show not too long ago and you same
thing but but I don't want to be in a
position where you root for the failure
of the country because you want the
failure of this one man if he if he fail
you know Sam did a piece right after the
election as much as Sam hates Trump he
said look now he's the pilot of the
plane so if you want the plane to crash
while you're on it so that that ain't
great right so I would say there's
probably nothing that they would really
ever give him credit for but I think at
the same time what they create is most
people in this country two years into a
trump presidency if you removed the the
tweets and the [ __ ] if you remove just
like the generic sort of screaming thing
all the time yeah well what actually is
happening the economy is still pretty
good like we're not does anyone think
Trump's gonna start nation-building
I actually think some of our alliances
are strong or even everyone else says
they're weaker I think some of the trade
stuff actually could start working on
our advantage I don't I don't know
exactly but I don't think there's
anything that they could really you
can't I mean I think you probably mostly
agree I definitely agree that okay so I
won't ask you this one cuz that I think
is a good question is from your super
chat yeah so talk about the art in the
studio what's the new art like Wow
so a
tacular artist her name is right there
kaylynn rose janet painted this painting
that's behind you and then the painting
that's behind me is sort of inspired
from that and one of the things that she
did she knows how much I love coffee so
you can see sort of the texture the
texture right binder that's actual
coffee grinds whoa that are in there
I think her website is cailin rosa CA y
li n Rose Janet calm nice and she's done
like there's tons of artwork in my house
that that she's done we have this huge
millennium view what coffee do you like
what's your cloud you have a coffee well
I like well I have I do French press and
I grinded in the morning of course the
whole thing yeah what do you do and like
no I hear something yeah I mean I have
an expressive but that's that's really
for the guests I don't find espresso I
could I could see you drinking Keurig
cuz you won't know because you wouldn't
put the effort into that that's right an
enduring coffee until like a month ago
you were talking this fast for all these
and then and then I was getting no sleep
one week and I had coffee and my show is
markedly better and I was like okay well
then I guess I have to take myself to be
okay even though you won't make me a
cake I will brew you a cup well I
appreciate it thank you thank you I mean
that's all I'm asking from you and then
also leave me alone by the way quick
note on that I would also mention that
like in Judaism it's not just like gay
marriage that's off limits its
intermarriage that's off limits so if a
member of my family were to intermarry
marry somebody who's not Jewish I
wouldn't go to the wedding really is it
yeah this is like it so even if that
would let's say it was your sister for
example even though I know she just got
married I met the guy
even if that would do irreparable damage
with your sister well in in in you know
my view the the irreparable damage is
being done by the fact that like if
you're brought up in a certain with a
certain sense of values and rules and
then you abandon those values and rules
then you know that's that's interesting
really intellectually I really can't
understand that and I think that we
we're living in a society that's because
of the loss of what clarity is were
that's part of why the fraying is
happening but it's like when we went out
to dinner that that IDW night we were at
that steak house and we all had these
Joe got this like you know giant
tomahawk that was for two people he
hated himself of course
say you Jordan had like the biggest
steak I've ever seen and Eric and I
split this porterhouse and it was so
freakin delicious and you brought your
dinner right he's your kosher so you're
obviously not gonna eat there and you
wouldn't even eat on their plates and
all that and I respect you making that
decision for yourself like I truly do I
truly do and I've family members do it
as a religious person yeah there is a
there is a constant conflict between
your role as a religious person and what
you may feel in your heart right so the
fact is that I want to keep out
everywhere yeah there are certain rules
about like when I'm supposed to wear a
yarmulke like if I walk into a place and
I'm not obviously carrying my own lunch
yeah it's actually a problem like
because people might think the
restaurant is kosher for example now and
then they're gonna eat there because
they saw this famous or non kosher
restaurant so that's something that you
have to take into account is that how
much are you conveying that your
religion approves of a particular
activity when you actually engage in the
particular activity and that that
applies to a wide variety of things it's
so interesting to me though because when
I came home that night I swear you can
ask David after I was like I was sitting
there in a second been brought I think
you brought a burger yeah and you're
eating your burger and I'm I know how
delicious this steak is and it's like I
really was like why would Ben deny
himself just this truly truly I smell
delicious yeah delicious thing but but
you do and that it doesn't because it's
part of a holistic lifestyle in which
you make choices about what you want
participating in what you don't but that
doesn't change even necessarily how you
feel about the people who are engaged in
particular activities it's just saying
like I as a religious person cannot
stamp with imprimatur like that this is
okay with me as a religious person but
that doesn't mean that I care about you
any less for example or I care about my
sister any less right if she did
something that I didn't like just in
terms of importance I'm gonna move the
steak away I'm not gonna force you to
think I still I think I'll be able to
get you to smoke a joint at some point
and I definitely am gonna be able to get
you say [ __ ] on camera though the last
one is actually not that far a leap if I
had a blue version of my show no I know
we'd be unbelievable I have somebody to
my show would be know real well Shapiro
perhaps some of the people we've been
talking to have some ideas for some new
show would be pretty well yeah okay so a
couple more here let's see
mmm okay this is this is a good one yeah
super chat question sorry I want to find
all the best ones here
no we're doing it live yeah exactly I'm
trying to read these that okay so the
ancient Greek proverb if you go to where
you better finish it or you'll leave it
to your grandchildren which I don't
think is actually from the ancient Greek
I think we didn't finish the war of
ideas against Marxism in the Cold War
and that is why we have a rise of
Marxism on college campuses today I'll
let you feel there first I think that my
basic answer would be yes we sort of let
this stuff fester as if it was the cool
stuff but I don't know what the
completion of a war of ideas is like you
damp things out to the point that no one
can speak of them that's not what we
want so so it's almost an unanswerable
question I think I think Jonah
Goldberg's answer on this is basically
correct which is that there's a human
tendency to buck against freedom and
that human tendency is why can't we
control the world around us why can't we
get together and solve all of our
problems why is it that free markets are
counterintuitive the idea if you leave
everybody alone your life is gonna be
better is relative usually the idea is
if I can control everybody around me
then my life will be better because I
can get them to do all the things I want
them to do I don't want to control
anybody right but I want my little piece
of the pie and I'm gonna do good work
here and but that's it but that's it
that's a cultivated idea yeah most as a
child right a little like when I look at
my children my children want to control
everything around them right including
me yeah and well and if you believe that
if we all get together we can build this
giant edifice together why can't you
just get on board just get on board then
Marxism has a certain kind of particular
draw especially when you look at the
fact there are rich people there are
poor people when you say to people well
right there gonna be some rich people
and some poor people but overall we're
getting richer that is more
counterintuitive than why can I just
steal that guy's money put it in my
pocket I'm better off yeah and so I
don't think that Marxism can never be
fully stamped out that said I think the
conservative movement has failed
markedly to make good arguments against
Marxism and they've basically made
arguments on the basis of efficacy
rather than morality they've said
basically Marxism it's a moral idea it
just is bad in administration and I
think Marxism is deeply immoral idea
that's also terrible all right so do you
think that's also why guys like like me
and you get so much hate because someone
like me I'm I was once something I had a
certain set of ideas I've shown you can
escape and survive
now there clearly is a massive movement
behind that I mean I know it I know it
is real the amount of young people that
are waking up and are going this thing
that they're gonna jam down your throat
in college and in high school is not
good it is not real it is not true and
there aren't many examples of people
escaping there was David Horowitz Italy
30 years ago or whatever but there's not
very modern example so that's why for
the for the it's not like I put out a
lot of hate but I seem to get a lot of
my online hate and I think that's the
reason and I think partly for you it's
it's similar to a different degree you
get it because you're willing to talk to
people like me and Sam and whoever else
so they're going the the real hardcore
people that hate all that stuff don't
want you to do it even though they love
you but they don't want you to do it
because they think that might give a
little extra bility exactly exactly okay
so somebody wants you to do a Trump
impersonation for the means very
important though what does he do so as
when he does people yeah I don't even
know what he does anymore you're fired I
gotta work on that stuff yeah yeah the
woods you're joining indeed you do any
good impersonations you do any good
impressions uh not I you know what I'll
come back with some decent I used to do
a great Cosby impression but then he
became the greatest serial naked naked
do you think make of the chocolate cake
okay enough was enough there's there's
only so much we can do here
it says let me put I better then can you
define what rights are I think there's a
disconnect between the left and the
right on what rights are well I believe
you are you are born free you have the
right to and in this country you have
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and then the Bill
of Rights lays out where your other
rights are the government has to protect
those rights it did not give you those
rights and I think that's the most
important thing the government did not
give me my freedom the government can
take away my freedom but it did not give
it to me so we have rights that are very
clearly laid out and again this is why I
don't want big government big government
in every way will trample on those
rights we have a beautiful system of
rights free speech the right to bear
arms the right to privacy all of those
things these are incredibly powerful
things but it's not because the
the government gave those rights to us
it's protecting what I think so I know
this is where conservatives usually
would say these are god-given rights I
think you can just say their their their
hue innately human rights that you you
are as a human being it is your
birthright you are born free can someone
grab you right out of the out of the
womb and put you in jail yes but you
were born free I think that's how I
basically achey an argument for the
philosophers in the room is that
basically you are born with particular
rights and these rights adhere to you by
virtue of you not having to get
something from someone else
you have a right to speak free because
that's not an imposition on anybody else
right a negative right versus a positive
right is the typical language that is
used conservatives believe in negative
rights people on the Left believe in
positive rights this would be like the
right to education where you can say to
the sky that you have a right to
education but unless you're actually
forcing a teacher to teach right then
there's no right right the same thing
right to housing right to healthcare the
left is very big now we got them start
on the impression it's not but you know
that that's right so the so the idea
there is that in a state of nature where
no one else is around you have these
particular rights you have the right to
make it to gotten labor you have the
right to control your labor you have the
right to speak freely of the rights of
free assembly to worship God how you
want you have the right to do all of
these things because you're not imposing
on anybody else the minute that you're
imposing on anybody else it's no longer
right so the bacon cake example is
actually a good one there are folks on
the Left who say you have a right to go
into somebody's shop and demand a
service from them the answer is you
don't have a right to go into somebody's
shop and demand a service from them
maybe you'd prefer if they give you that
service maybe it's smarter if they give
you that service maybe it's more moral
if they give you that service but you
don't have the right to go and demand
service from anyone from anyone else
because rights are things that I am NOT
demanding from you the folk side of that
is duties which is because you have a
right to life I have I have a duty not
to kill you but I would have that duty
not to kill you regardless of whatever
you call that right okay so while you
were gone apparently there are a bunch
of people who have been asking about
whether you are indeed funded by the
nefarious evil terrible Koch brothers or
so it's give you the opportunity to
answer why you were in the pay of the
shekel masters all right first off well
if anyone wants to know if this thing is
edited or not I think there you go okay
I'm glad you asked actually because this
is just endless drivel that is you know
this is partly one of the things about
just online nonsense it's like you could
spend all day defending
yourself about untrue claims and the
attacks that we get in personal attacks
and it's like often ina and Sam when I
had him on last time a couple months ago
he said for the two years that he was
under endless assault he almost views
all his defense as wasted time because
often know the truth the truth will
it'll set you free it'll it'll it's the
right thing the truth but often if
you're if you're debating against or
your protagonist or attackers don't care
about truth then you're just feeding
them by giving them anything you're just
feeding more insanity which is why I
haven't I think I've maybe I've even
addressed this publicly I'm not even
sure okay so here's the deal
and I've been completely transparent
about this the entire time it's so
stupid so learn Liberty which is they
produce one show of ours a month they've
given us incredible professors like
Deirdre McCloskey and Randy Barnett and
Steve Davies and Sean hopwood and people
from all and Thaddeus Russell people
from all over the political map they
produce one show a month they give us a
list of professors I can pick any of
them and if I don't like any of them I
can pick anyone else they've given us
people all over the political map
they've sponsored our episode with Phil
DeFranco the youtuber they had never
even met him or at any interaction with
him they just liked him so I said learn
liberty at the top this episode is
brought to you by learning liberty or
our friends at you learn liberty
whatever and then they donated they were
gonna give him a little bit of money he
didn't even want it they donated it to a
to a cause that he cares about so I
think what has happened here is that
learn liberty is a subsidiary or in
partnership with Institute for Humane
studies which I think is through George
Mason University and I believe that
David Koch one of the Koch brothers is
on the board there and must give some
money to it I know for a fact that the
person who has funded our relationship
my relationship with learn liberty is an
anonymous woman and I know that because
they told me that she's anonymous and
that it's a woman and I personally wrote
her a thank-you note I want to be 100
percent spectacularly crystal-clear they
have had no control over our content I
ask whatever questions I want we never
never edit for content we did once in my
hundreds of interviews it was with the
celebrity for a reason that is
completely irrelevant not important they
they have never told me anything to say
they there is nothing there is literally
nothing untoward here and I've and I've
always I always start the episode by
saying we're funded or were we're in
partnership with learn liberty so we're
funded by learn liberty for that one
episode anyway this is just endless
dribble and I it's almost like you can
see I'm sort of yeah it's like I don't
even want to talk about it because it's
like this is all [ __ ] this is all
distracting [ __ ] and it's like
that's all nonsense and the amount that
we get from em by the way pales in
comparison to what we're trying to build
on patreon and everything else so it's
like no no one has ever told me to say
anything no one has even ever asked me
to say anything I've never had contact
with the cokes no one has ever said
anything and by the way I would love to
interview the cokes I would have
literally no problem the cokes fund the
cokes fund you know Lincoln Center and I
think they put money towards PBS and all
sorts they're a parent yeah so like I
don't have a problem with any of that
so just to be crystal clear for anyone
listening to this or for any of these
people that just relentlessly hate me or
whatever I am not funded by the Koch
brothers so I guess what you're saying
is you're funded by the Koch brothers
there are a million there are millions
of people in this country who are who
donate to nonprofits and it's like if
you work with the nonprofit you might be
then you're in coats and obviously
control it's just it's so dumb I hope we
clean that up but you know I know it'll
just give endless all right so here's it
here's another super chat question play
prognosticator what our president
Trump's chances of reelection in 2020 I
would say based short of it some sort of
impeachment thing and I have to catch up
on a little bit of the news that you
enlighten me on I would say basically
pretty good if the left's decision to go
down the road of identity politics and
Social Democrats socialist Democrats
whatever the hell they're called now but
the Bernie keith Ellison wing which is a
which is basically an extremist wing of
a party then they're gonna be in a lot
of trouble if though if is there any
blue dog democrat left if that thing
could come back a sensible liberal
believe me i could vote for someone
who's probably a little more big
government than i am i wish and i talked
about it for years
I want my used to say my guys I wanted
my side but left the Democrats to wake
up there's no sign whatsoever that
they're gonna wake up potentially look
if they get slammed in the midterms then
maybe they wake up but
you you're predicting that they won't I
suspect it's not going to be that bad
actually if you're a Republican because
I don't think there's anyone who voted
for Trump that suddenly looks at the
left and thinks that they're better no I
mean but their numbers may just be
depressed they may just not show up and
that's always what happens in midterms
and it's never good for the incumbent
president's party and all that stuff but
I suspect generally what they're
offering is so it really is fringe and
the only reason we don't think it's
fringe is because the mainstream media
jams it down our throat every day and
when if we can get that message out to
people and I think you're particularly
effective at doing it but we needed to
also get to people that won't listen to
Ben Shapiro right we need to get to
people that'll listen to me or whoever
else people that listen to Joe Rogan or
whatever even though I know we all have
a lot of crossover if that message could
get out there this thing that's being
sold to you is so obvious and good and
the government can fix everything and
blah blah blah if we can show them that
is a fringe idea here are some better
ways to freedom then I think forget
Trump for a second I just think that
that's a much better path for a healthy
session I'm at in the political
prognostication business since I lost
10,000 dollars in the last election by
the way I was with you the night of the
election which I've told many people
well I've said yeah I think we've talked
about it publicly but watching you that
night you know it was entertaining it
was like it was like being with like
eight different people trying to burst
out upon by you know I'm more skeptical
that President Trump is heading a good
path just because his approval ratings
are so low and there's only a referendum
on him once every four years so I think
that you know 2018 is shaping a pretty
ugly for Republicans the turnout numbers
don't look good Democrats are over
representing pretty much everywhere in
the early elections do I think it's
gonna be like a 60cc blowout no but I
think there's a good shot Democrats what
about 35 seats in the house again I
could be completely wrong here right so
is the scariest part of that bode but
let's okay so let's say the Democrats
take back the house and it's just
endless investigations yeah I think it's
done for a couple of years also here's
the thing president Trump is riding on
excellent news for the past couple of
years he's it like 42 percent in the
polls usually 43 percent in the polls he
benefited number one from Gary Johnson
and Jill Stein winning a combined I
think six seven percent of the vote in
the last election cycle but also he has
benefited now from a great economy and
no major foreign policy crisis
we're overdue for some sort of economic
downturn and there's one every eight to
ten years in the country it's been since
2008 so I'm a little you know God God
willing we avoid it and it just
continues to be strong because it'd be
good for the country but if finally that
the idea that the president is so in
charge he's not he's nearly any of the
economy it's it's the I think the
president put a serious damper on the
economy but I don't think that the
president can be held responsible for
the performance of a particular economy
again when people say Obama is great for
the economy cycle so was the Republican
Congress great for the economy because
they were there since 2010 all of that
said you know I think Democrats are
gonna turn out in droves
in in 2020 in a way they didn't in 2016
the real story 2016 to me was no one
showed up to vote for Hillary Clinton
like we're all focused on Trump cuz he's
the center of the universe but the
reality is that was a referendum on
Hillary not a referendum on Trump
Trump's approval ratings were absolutely
stable they were always between 40 and
44 percent Hillary's bounced around from
40 to 50 because people would say oh
well maybe she'll be good and then
they'd look above god-awful right and
they just wouldn't show up you want
fewer votes in the state of Donald Trump
point fewer votes in the state of
Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did in 2012
Trump won the state of Wisconsin Romney
lost the state of Wisconsin because no
one should have to vote for Hillary
Clinton
I think Democratic turnout in 2020 is
going to be real high Trump has to win
somewhere between 12 and 14 million
additional votes between 2016 and 2020
in order to win because George W had to
win an additional 10 million votes to
win and he only lost by 500,000 in the
popular vote so how can that how can
Republicans win Democrats can be awful
right I mean that's that's what you're
basically saying yeah and so it's always
a head-to-head matchup
yeah if Democrats run Kamala Harris
Trump will win if Democrats run
Elizabeth Warren I think Trump probably
wins if they were on kirsten gillibrand
who will definitely won if they run Joe
Biden I think it's an uphill run for
president Trump in sad that is that
you'd need to bring in this out of the
house 72 years old
oh god it'll be 74 he'll be 78 Ron will
be 74 and the two of them will just Club
each other with their canes
they don't like you know mean tennis
balls will go through running on the
bottom of those Walker's yeah okay
here's here's one as a practicing June
as an atheist what are both of your
thoughts on the swing toward sexual
freedom of sexual freedom pre marriage
has it negatively affected long-term
relationships can I hit this well first
up I would say this is why okay
practicing
so it this is we're saying you're a
practicing Jew is a little it's hard to
know what that means because I would say
you're on the sort of more modern
orthodox described but strict side of
that and now you're ready and do your
okay
versus the dispersion into laws married
yes right okay okay so you are okay so I
would say this this is another reason
where people should basically be for gay
marriage not from the libertarian
perspective although of course that's I
think the most honest perspective is
that the government shouldn't be in your
business but also from a if you think
you know I think the when the right was
really fear-mongering for many years
about gays and the Huckabee's and the
evangelicals were always you know and
george w bush because of karl rove you
know used gay marriage as a wedge issue
and they were saying well look at the
gays they're all having all this sex and
they're doing all these drugs and about
well guess what if you don't let people
have the same ability to love someone
that they love if you don't let people
enter the same exact legal protections
as everybody else then people are going
to act out in all sorts of ways sexually
drugs all sorts of things i did all
sorts of things I never thought I was
going to I never really thought about
marriage I just didn't I
I was closeted for a long time I think I
was all sorts of wacked out in many ways
but if you take a certain subset of
people and say to them you can't have
the things that other people have that
will eventually maybe allow you to have
a family or whatever else and you say
you can't havelis well then every all
your sex is going to be premarital so if
your answer is well because I hear this
sometimes people will say well gays
should just be you can be gay but just
be celibate you know that's what I mean
it's ridiculous and it's like you have
to this is why gays are conservatives I
think really it's it's happened already
so it doesn't even really matter but
it's like you should be for gay marriage
in a way that actually is for all the
other things you're for because you guys
want a certain same sex marriage case
for same-sex marriage is the one that
you just made it's even better than the
the equal rights argument because equal
rights argument you could easily say
well the role of marriage in between a
man a woman and man man is a little bit
different just because of natural
childbearing and rearing that occurs and
this is by the way why you guys didn't
make this argument before right like you
weren't pounding the liberty
an argument for gay marriage eight years
ago I started hitting it in about
2012-2013 so that was probably a little
bit before most conservatives came on
but generally libertarians even were I
guess deliberate real libertarians my
basic idea was basically I want the
government out of everything the
government sucks at everything but as
far as the the argument in favor of
same-sex marriage if the argument is in
favor of stable you know two-person
relationships as opposed to wild
promiscuity in every circumstance that
is going to be superior but imagine
imagine telling a subset of people I
mean imagine if the world was roars gays
report the majority and straights
whatever and I said to you Ben you
cannot marry a woman well now you're
gonna do all sorts of things like it
just is I hear I hear the argument it's
interesting cuz I think we actually have
a slight disagreement here if somebody
were to say that to me then my argument
be well I don't understand why societal
institutions would make the decision for
me as to whether I should live with one
person or not well the meaning that like
even if society says like as a person
who is libertarian on the government
issue of marriage my vision is well I go
to my synagogue and that provides me the
of illegitimate see I feel like I need
with my spouse which is why I say like
if gay people want to get married in
their church go for it like anyway but
it's but it's you know I think it's hard
to make the case that promiscuity is
deeply connected with lack of same-sex
marriage I think that promiscuity is is
connected with personal decision making
just because what you see is that
there's a riot wild raise rise and
promiscuity in the street communicate
the gay community there's a wild rise in
rates of promise Neverland swipe and
right in or I guess you swipe left if
you want it no idea if there's a swipe
in the wrong I know it's all about a
swipe that is it but it's it but if you
look at the rates of single motherhood
for example those have been on the rise
since the 1960s and that's in a
situation where straight people are
allowed to get married and they have
been allowed to get married
historically so right though so
correlating the institution of marriage
with with promiscuity I think is a
difficult argument to make just
statistically speaking okay so we'd have
somebody but the argument is that that
institutionalizing marriage will make
people less promiscuous then I think
that's actually that that's the best
argument for same-sex marriage I think
that's out there if I were gonna steal
man the same sex marriage argument that
be the argument you need more stable
relationships you need less instability
you need people who feel that that's
actually a positive societal good to
live with one person is
living with a hundred other people you
know that's that's it you know that that
I think is the strongest argument so are
you saying you're for enforced monogamy
man but it is it is true that a society
that every social science study ever
done has shown that when people live
together a long time before marriage
they tend to get divorced at higher
rates than they would if they weren't if
they'd just gotten married basically and
the reason for that is I think that if
you if you look at the at the research
on passion and and sort of committed
love they move in opposite directions
over the course of relationships when
you first meet somebody your passion
level is incredibly high and your level
of committed love meaning you know I
know this person really well I can count
on this person is really low and then
about six months in passionate love
those like that committed love goes like
that which is why if you've been married
ten years like I have then you know I'm
really passionate about my wife but to
pretend that it's the same level of like
sexual tension that's somebody that I'm
dating as ten years later with two kids
of course that's not true now it doesn't
mean I have bad sex like I have a
wonderful sex life but it's a different
thing than it was at the very beginning
well if you correlate in your mind that
what's great about a relationship is a
passion level and then and then you live
together with somebody for six months
and then you get married and then your
passion level decreases you mistake the
the correlation for the causation its
marriage that causes passion level to
decline not the fact that I've been
living with someone for a while also the
fact is that the reason people aren't
getting married in general and in
society where you're allowed to get
married gay or straight is because you
don't want to that means that you're
already got an eye on the door in many
cases and that's not a real flattering
idea for a lot of folks so you know
pretty I think promiscuity is first of
all I think that one of the worst lies
perpetrated against women is that women
and men treat sex in exactly the same
way which is absurd the the idea that
promiscuity is good for women in the
same way that it is quote unquote good
for men is fully insane I don't think is
good for either there are a moral
perspective from a spiritual perspective
from a health perspective but I think
that the amount of damage that has done
spiritually to women who are who are
promiscuous on average not for every
individual it's a pretty country do what
you want but the on average the amount
of psychological damage that is done to
sixteen-year-old girls for Miss Goose is
not nearly the same amount of damage the
the it's wildly disproportionate to two
men who are having right likewise
so I correlative the guy in high school
who's like banging a lot of the
cheerleaders doesn't it doesn't stick
with him in a sort of psychologically
suicide rates among young men who are
promiscuous is not even close to the
suicide rate among young ladies actual
correlation between earlier sex for
young women particularly and and suicide
rates that's because women and men and
we all used to know this but women and
men treat sex differently because women
and men are not the same yeah we should
do it well I want to do some big IDW
panels in general maybe do some stuff
live and I think we're discussing all
sorts of stuff and all that but this
would be a really rich topic for sure
because it does raise questions as to
like what should we promote as a society
now forget about government regulation
and what should merchants order the
basics what are the basic social
institutions that are necessary and is
it possible that we totally effed up
relations between the sexes and the
future of long term relationships and
marriage by separating sex from marriage
in a really significant way which which
began really before - even the sixties I
mean there's a there's a decline in
marriage that it started before even the
advent of the sexual revolution per se
let's see maybe a couple more yeah okay
so you're a good man I know you have a
real job and everything oh yeah I know I
have to go write a bunch of crap after
this so let's see another another one
we'll do it let's do the last one here
so okay that's a political scale with
statism on the left and anarchy on the
right this from patreon where
constitutional constitutionalism why is
a bit right-of-center
make more sense than the traditional
left-right scale we use where does
Liberty lie on the traditional
left-right scale I feel like we could do
something a little more exciting okay
let's say I mean I don't we both do that
one in 30 seconds that's like a little
more excited the 30 second answer is
that statism on the left anarchy on the
right is basically the American
political scale the the European
political scale is nationalism versus
international right and so we're
shifting towards that we are shifting
toward that and it's dangerous like I
think that the political skillets as
statism is on the left and anarchy is on
the right I think that that's that is a
better scale I think it's a more
accurate scale yeah I don't mean to
dismiss the question and I'll do more
something on this question on patreon
itself but but for our big finish here I
feel like yeah come out of benching
here we go here we go them would you
agree would you agree with the idea that
classically speaking the left hand
right have a fundamental disagreement on
human nature a man being inherently good
or evil keep up the great work
yeah let's do human nature first let me
just tell you what I believe I believe
people are basically good I believe you
are you are born I think I pretty much
buy into Pinker's blank slate but I
think you you're basically born good
there's something innately human that
you want to do good doesn't mean we do
good all the time we all do all sorts of
things we lie and we cheat and we do
this and that and and and you have
moments in your life where we could all
look back know whoa you know couple of
years I was really doing some
self-destructive [ __ ] or or some
whatever it is but I think there is
something uniquely human about wanting
to do good it's how it's how human
flourishing has existed it's not just
because of the stuff that we can
empirically test and all that there is
something else about being human that
little spark that you see in a baby's
eye when they know something's funny and
they can't even speak like there is
something else that is that is there
that is human that is good and I think
it's sort of your job to try to enhance
that as much as possible at least I see
that as my job and I'm trying and I I
will fail often and I'll continue to
fail but I'm really trying to be the
best person that I can be while I am
here and I think that comes from
something that's way before me that
comes from something that I can't prove
with tools here and measurements like
it's just something that is I think
that's probably a little bit of what
your answer is but maybe not to a lot of
folks on the left the idea that human
beings are inherently good means that if
we just unshackle you from the bounds of
society it's sort of the Rousseau idea
that this was that your innate goodness
will spring forth and everything will be
great
or from the Markson idea if you just
change the economic system then we will
all be inherently better and we'll see
each other as brothers as opposed to
enemies so I am of the kind of founding
fathers idea which is basically a
biblical idea which is that people are
not angels and not Devils we're human
beings their capacity for good we have
capacity for evil Wow
I love my two and a half year old son
he's a nutcase and and were he an adult
he would be the worst person in the
world he
you know he wants what he wants and he
wants it when he wants it and he doesn't
care about hitting people and so you
don't think he's innately good or
innately evil you think he just is as a
human and and it's sort of your job as a
parent this is what society's did
civilization and inculcating virtue
that's your job as an adult and I think
that the danger in the belief that
people aren't errantly good is the idea
if you just free them everything is okay
well freedom from political institutions
is one thing but freeing them from
social fabric and social institutions is
a whole nother thing so this is where I
would say this is why I still consider
myself a classical liberal and not a
libertarian because I do think there is
some role for government and it's to
protect those things and for me it's not
even about the role of government who
are libertarians really go wrong is the
suggestion that social institutions are
the cause of all the world's evil so
that what we really need is get rid of
knocked down all the churches knock down
all of the the places that are
inculcating virtue and right of course
but but you know somebody asks here
about debating our own Brooke I've
invited yarn on my program for
specifically this cuz I ran so are you
guys doing it I know I know he wants me
I mean I love too happy to do it here I
mean I think that we disagree on less
than I I think that there's some
semantic games being played about about
objectivism and what exactly is
self-interest in all this are happy I'm
happy to do that but it's but with that
said I think that recognizing the human
beings are capable of evil is a deeply
important thing to recognizing that you
have to as an adult cultivate your
children in a way that they are going to
be good so is that is that different
though than what I said because I
believe we are born good but it doesn't
mean that evil said I don't act evilly
or or that evil can so I don't generate
through a lot of people yeah I mean I'm
very reticent to use the language we're
born good yes I don't think that babies
are born with an innate I think I'm born
with a basic basic innate moral sense
but it's really basic and non cultivated
and I think that if you had a babies
morality if the gut if the world are run
by babies we'd all be dead and not just
because they're know because they're
they're not moral they're not moral
creatures they want what they want when
they want it I think that that's
something that has to be cultivated by
by society and reason is something that
must be cultivated over time and that's
why it's a constant attempt by anyone
who's good to try and say okay what is
impacting memories in here is a passion
that's in
packing my reason is it bias that's
impacting my reason what is it that's
that's making me unreasonable about this
thing and more reasonable we are
hopefully the better we are as human
beings as we've actually fully
considered the the ramifications of the
of the policies that were pursuing in
the actions that we're taking in our
daily lives so I'm very into the the
risk of the what we call it in Judaism
the gates are hurrah they you know I
mean you know this right there's the H I
tell them there's the H ah there's kind
of the good inclination the bad
inclination and the idea in Judaism is
they're constantly a war with one
another and it's your job to try and
strengthen the eighths or hatov so that
it overcomes the atera I think that's
the struggle of mankind and it's a it's
a Christian notion as well I mean the
idea of the the fall you know in the sin
is now embedded in you and even after
after Jesus is coming about yourself to
struggle with that obviously it's tough
struggle with the the Satan behind you
basically but I think that recognizing
the capacity for evil is perhaps the
first step in becoming good and so this
is why I'm extraordinarily reticent to
say man is naturally good I think man is
naturally neither I think man is
naturally driven toward self-interest
and nastiness and tribalism and evil and
man is naturally driven to to fight that
sort of stuff in in a variety of ways
but it requires an act of will in order
to overcome all of those other
inclinations yeah and I can I can get on
board all that and I still my
fundamental believe is that people are
good but you still you do have to
cultivate
I think people in Western society are
good and I think that's that's an
outgrowth of several thousand years of
history I think that if we dropped you a
lot I think if we dropped in the middle
of Afghanistan you'd be pretty effed I'd
be probably very different than I am
right now as Peterson always says on
this topic the Devils in the details so
well I got to tell you man first off
thank you for doing this I know you're
busy as hell and I'm and you know you
were the right guy to sit down yeah and
as I say I'm always happy to wreck your
day so yeah you know this it's I'm glad
that we also end it on this note because
this that conversation that we just had
I think is what I think really matters
and I think that's why people are shown
you know thousands of people are showing
up to your live events thousands of
people are showing up to these events
that I'm doing with Peterson and by the
way we're duel I've stream later but we
just extended the tour into 2019 people
don't want
this endless bloodshed this mutually
assured destruction and I'll keep trying
and what is obvious is that headline of
the day is less important than the Big
Ideas and so trying to escape headline
of the days sounds like it was a good
idea for you yeah all right well thank
you Shapiro I'm gonna go here for one
second that's my camera right in my
studio over here all right so here's
what we're gonna do I will do a we
launched a whole bunch of stuff today so
I finally got Dave Rubin calm after 10
or 15 years of trying to leave an
all-new website
we launched an all new patreon this
morning that I want to do a live stream
and talk to you guys about because I
really want to start doing some some new
community building as you can see we
have a new set we have new graphics we
have new music I'm sure you're all
commenting on all of those things so
I'll do a live stream probably in about
an hour or two so we'll post that and
again thanks to Shapiro over here and
we'll set up that thing with Brooke and
what can i pimp anything else out for
you and go check out my pocket that's
Ben Shapiro show have you heard of the
Ben Shapiro show all right thanks for
watching everybody
you